good morning
welcome to the full committee work
session on House Bill 639
Weir will not be taking public testimony
today however we have invited the
experts in the agencies to be here with
us in case we have technical questions
so thank you for being here
uh so we're going to focus really on
just this bill today and our goal is no
matter how long it takes today we're
going to figure out what possible types
of amendments we might have on this bill
our plan is to exec this next Monday
March 27th because we'll be up against
deadline so of course we want to make
sure we spend all the time we need this
week to make sure our amendments are
typographically correct and do what we
intend them to do
so we talked about the fact that we're
going to be focusing on the the revenue
aspects of this bill and not the
underlying policy
because that's already been addressed by
another committee
one there's several key things we wanted
to talk about today but of course
probably the biggest one is the tax rate
because that is definitely in our
purview so I'd like to start focusing on
that conversation and then of course we
have to have a conversation about well
where does the money go and then of
course we have to have a conversation
about the housekeeping type of
Corrections that need to be done that
have been pointed out
so with that I'll open it up to the
committee to talk about the tax rate
that is entertained in 639
representative Olney
I thought we'd be listening to the
agencies first the agencies don't have a
position on this they are here to answer
any technical questions you have or
informational questions you have but
they did put certain things that are
kind of positions in the
the fiscal note that we have
we can certainly bring whoever you want
up just let me know who well
I can I can bring this up first okay
all right so representative almie's
going to hand out some things
oops
while we're waiting I just wanted to
remind everyone that our deadline our
crossover is April 6th so plan to be
busy until through April 6. I am
personally planning to not schedule
anything the week the next week the week
of April 10th
so that all of you including myself can
get a little r r so that's kind of our
vacation week before we have to start
attacking uh the Senate bills that come
over so okay
foreign
so
I get I just gave away my copy
this one we got plenty extras on that
side it looks like
on
I have a real problem with a cultivator
tax
and you can't
the people that are going to be deciding
what prices
the cultivators get it's going to be
between large
agribusiness firms from that are
probably from outside the state that are
going to come in and stick up green hat
large greenhouses
it's too expensive
for most farmers
if you grow outside on you have a great
deal of problem with droughts with
floods with insects and viruses
and it damages the quality of your crop
and
and the Liquor Commission is going to
have to do a lot more testing
it seems to me in order to guarantee
on the what outside cultivation gets
done I know there was one
person that came at the hearing who
is a farmer and is growing hemp and
thinks that he can handle this
um
but
the Farm Bureau and the farmers around
the state that they consulted with I'll
say they want no part of it
of marijuana cultivation because it's
going to be taken over by large
out-of-state on Farm
on agribusinesses
and that they won't be able to compete
with them
so
they did not want to come here to
testify to that they said we're just
staying away from the whole thing
I spent a lot of time getting a hold of
the head of the Farm Bureau who didn't
want to talk to me about it and then
talking to him so
um
and
I did want to go back to something like
the meals and rooms tax but I'm not sure
um what I have here is a hybrid
in the tobacco tax we have a secondary
tax which is collected in and um
and rate uh the rates are very different
from the rest of the tobacco tax which
is on on Vape
vaping products
and I felt that we could
easily treat this as a hybrid between
that and the rooms in males text that is
collected like the rooms in males tax
from the retailers
um
but on
regard it as
as an offshoot of the tobacco tax
because it is a smoking
usually a smoking uh
device and the tobacco tax itself
contains things that you don't smoke you
just stick behind your upper lip or
or
uh
or do something like that uh
so
what I've got most of this document is
is a list of all of the states according
to ncsl in February
of
um that have passed
uh marijuana
taxation
not not just legalization some of them
um are still in the process of
of
setting it up
so that they aren't terribly useful to
us in terms of of uh
how they're doing with the tax that
they're putting on but this is not just
the tax that they usually put out this
is that Tax Plus any sales tax is excise
taxes
cultivator taxes there are
are two that are taxing at the
cultivator level not one I think not one
um Illinois
does both gross does growth receipts on
the
on the grower
and sales taxes
on the consumer
on
and so
what I tried to do was put together as
much of as that as I could a lot of them
have local sales taxes that also apply
and you don't know whether that sales
tax is going to play certain places can
be zero or it's going to be 25 percent
so I just said or and local sales taxes
New Jersey just passed something in 2020
on I don't think it's working yet
their sales their state sales tax is
only 6.6 percent
they say the locals can tax up to two
percent that's the only one that put a
cap on it
um
and Vermont
made theirs their marijuana consumption
legal
but the sales part of it was only passed
in 2020.
so that's still very preliminary in what
kinds of
uh success that they're having with
attacks which is really 20.8 percent
when you finish adding up things
plus whatever local sales tax I haven't
run into a local sales tax in Vermont
but
but I'm only on the usually on the
western side of this Eastern side of the
state and they compete with us
so
so they probably didn't
um
and I I highlighted our neighbors the
nearest after that is New Jersey and New
Jersey is just starting
um
so
and New Jersey's
is six points the 6.6 percent and up to
two percent they would be competitive if
people wanted to drive that far
with anything that we do
it was passed by a voter initiative and
so the legislators didn't have any say
in that so
on the other two states are main
which has a 16.1 percent cumulative
sales and excise tax I think it is and
all of this is from a bulletin that's in
uh NCS
ncsl's files it's the most recent uh
of them
and I tried to reach the author
yesterday and couldn't
but
um
so Maine is 16.1 percent cumulative I
multiplied the the two taxes and
took away one uh
to get this to that point and they also
have a cultivator or processor tax it's
not clear which maybe someone who lives
near Maine knows
um
on on that is fairly low up to 2.93
percent on weight
um
I used for the weight weight ones I
I used the methodology that represented
The Honorable around me
and his commission used a couple of
years ago which is based on work in New
York state
so
and Massachusetts
comes to 17.7 percent and local sales
taxes which I think are pretty prevalent
in Massachusetts
so that's
I thought looking at that
that we could easily have a 10 or a 12
percent
um
excise tax on
on marijuana uh
by by
price at the retail level
and
and be able to compete quite handily in
in our neighborhood
maybe not with New Jersey
thank you representative Pleasant yes
I'm going to question uh representative
almi
um I heard you start out saying that
it'll be run by large out-of-state
agriculture firms coming in here and
setting up greenhouses what's that got
to do with where we tax
well it's got several things to do with
it one of them is one we've already
discussed which is that it is extremely
difficult to
get to the actual cost on that you tax
the cultivator on if the cultivator is
owned and run and managed by the The
Firm that is also processing it and then
selling it even selling it at retail
perhaps but certainly processing it
in my view this uh in my view this this
attacking at the cultivator level will
work as long as it's illegal at a
federal level as soon as the feds make
it legal it won't work and we'll have to
go to a distributor level but the
question is do we want to change that
now because there's a lot of momentum
for the cultivator level yeah and if I
could just
we repeat when when we have a vertically
integrated business which is doing
the cultivation and the processing and
then possibly in retail also but on they
as we found out with the communication
Services tax and some other things on
the that firm pretty much gets to set
what they act what they say that they're
selling themselves
as a price
and if the tax is at the cultivator
level they will set that as low as
possible
although I I agree representative army
they shouldn't be set in the market
themselves then being the middleman and
being the retailer what's the best
approach in in addressing that is it
right here in simple language is it in
rules where would be the best place to
approach that
all right I saw another hand over here I
apologize
no
okay could I just respond yeah I think
that we need to ask the Liquor
Commission which or dra I'm not sure
which of them I think the Liquor
Commission is going to be responsible
for
taking in the tax
so the question is how will the value be
termed be determined that this
cultivator tax will be based on so is
there someone in the audience who can
help us answer that definition is it in
this bill or is that something we should
be very specific about
I saw your hand yes representative Ames
um I'd like to hear a response to your
a question there but um
but it may help us
to know that all of us to know that in
Illinois where they seem to have an
identical tax but also some other taxes
in their statute and this response to
what representative Doucette was asking
they try to spell out what to do with a
vertical vertically integrated uh entity
and uh here's what they say
the department their Department of
Revenue I guess May determine the
selling price of the Cannabis when the
seller and purchaser are affiliated
persons when the sale and purchase of
cannabis is not an arm's length
transaction or when cannabis is
transferred by a craft grower to the
craft Growers dispensing organization or
infuser or processing organization and
the value is not established for the
Cannabis the value to turn by the
department shall be commensurate with
the actual price received for products
of light quality character and use in
the area if there are no sales of
cannabis of like of like quality
character and use in the name same area
then the department shall establish a
reasonable value based on sales of
products of like quality character and
use in other areas of the state taking
into any into consideration any other
relevant factors so I assume that some
rule making that would follow from this
sort of overlay of how you do it and and
that's how they're doing it in Illinois
I had sent around
I think it was a link to maybe it was
text as well to the Illinois
statute which I think is the only one I
could find this explicitly just a
cultivator tax and then there's a retail
tax but the cultivator tax is seven
percent
and it seems to be on the gross receipts
just like well we're looking at here
um and when I sent that out last night I
didn't have any information on revenues
specific to that tax there's lots of
money flowing into Illinois but of
course it's a huge State it's 10 times
our size population wise but there's
lots of money flowing in but how much of
it is
from this part of the tax structure and
this morning Jennifer poor
who's always a step ahead
um gave me a
printout from
from Illinois that is very interesting
to me anyway
and it's just a piece and I don't think
this year I know exactly how it fits
into the overall picture and how final
it is but it's by by region in in
in Illinois and the most interesting
thing to me is that
they should they have a retail sales tax
as well as this cannabis
cultivate cultivator tax
um and they're collecting about the same
amount of money from each
the retail sales tax I think is a higher
rate
and I don't have that in front of me I
sorry but uh it varies in each region
it's almost exactly you know slightly
different but almost exactly the same
amount of money collected from each of
these taxes so they're getting
significant money from their seven
percent
tax on
on the product at its cultivation level
and then they're getting an equal amount
of money when it's sold and it adds up
to twice that so
um
I think some of these questions about
how difficult this is to have this kind
of tax if we could only get uh
someone from Illinois to
inform us that would be great maybe we
can't but that's some information that
may be useful to everybody
representative Elber
thank you madam chair I'd like to get
back to the numbers uh one of the things
that representative Ami mentioned was
that she's thinking she would think more
in the uh rate of about 10 to 12 percent
you have here written somewhere between
12 and 15 percent for retail tax and if
one of the purposes is to try to have a
lower tax rate than our
neighborly competitors
why not go with the higher end of that
of 15 which is still
two and a half percent lower
than Massachusetts and four and a half
percent lower than Maine
would you like to respond to that I'd
just like to get some information from
liquor and or dra about how they'd
actually what this would require at
least at the beginning is determining
the price
to that the cultivator would have to pay
on the the price per weight that the
cultivator would have to pay at the
beginning
of the process yes we will ask them to
come up yeah but I saw a hand up here
representative Pillsbury thank you madam
chair
um to a question you post several
minutes ago and further on
representative Ames comment
the bill doesn't have any language that
gets to the question of how you would
determine value or what would happen in
the case of a transfer a pricing
situation
the closest
it gets to is on page 22.
all the way to the bottom in lines 35 to
this is part four under the section that
relates to the tax
and that simply says the commission
shall adopt rules under RSA 541a
relative to the tax rate to tax rates
and procedures for licensed cannabis
cultivation facilities that also hold a
cannabis product manufacturing facility
license or retail cannabis store license
so it's only addressed in the sense that
there's a delegation of rule making
Authority and no guidance
weigh in on this or give us your inside
view you've spent a lot more time on
this than we have
foreign
Madam chair members of the committee for
the record Joseph Mullica chairman of
the New Hampshire Liquor Commission
so if the question is how would we go
about
taxing this
first and foremost The Liquor Commission
is obviously neutral on this
but if we were going to if we were going
to tax it that would be that would all
be set in rule that would be done in
rule just those same way we've done with
our with our liquor rules
most importantly to The Liquor
Commission is
we're a business
we want to be able to compete with the
states around us everybody's got a head
start on this so the first and the first
thing is just like we do with our liquor
products every day
we checked neighboring prices we adjust
prices accordingly so if we're going to
have
we're going to be setting the price
we wouldn't allow someone who was
manufacturing to set a price just just
like we wouldn't allow someone who was
manufacturing to set a retail price in
our liquor stores they they we would we
would check what the competition is
doing and we would uh we would set the
price according to what the competition
was doing now if there was a product
that was being produced here that wasn't
being produced in another state we would
use the expertise of of The Growers and
manufacturers what I've seen in my trips
to Maine and I've been to outdoor
facilities I've been to indoor
facilities
kind of the repertoire that I hear is
Max Massachusetts completely over taxes
this product
uh
Maine's
Revenue
in 2020 on this product was 4.3 million
in 2021 it was 82 million
in 2022 was 159 million
and in 2023 it's projected to be around
180 plus million give or take
rounding the numbers they have about 97
stores 48 manufacturing facilities and
about 75 cultivators
in 2022 that 159 million gave the state
16 million dollars in tax revenue but
one of the things I hear from the
cultivators in Maine is they're very
displeased with the tax that they have
to pay
on the on the flower the 335 dollars a
pound or the 94 dollars a pound on the
trim when they transfer it over they
feel that that is raising the price of
their product because then on top of
that the state is adding their excise
tax
so we felt in
speaking originally with this about with
chairman hunt that if we could set the
price accordingly in the state of New
Hampshire
we're dealing with a produce product so
just like anything else that's grown and
anything else that's sold big S small D
small D big S it's a supply and demand
product so as different times of the
year the product fluctuates in price
when there's a lot of of product that's
been manufactured the price is going to
be lower at certain times of year when
there's less of the product the product
is going to be higher in fact there's
some manufacturers in Maine that will
cultivate their flour and hold it
it's a hedge they're waiting for the
price to go up so they can make more
money on it
so that this is the type of thing that
if we could set the price according to
the markets around us
when we get the product in we feel that
we could be more competitive I I would
think that the goal is to sell more
product than anybody around us we can
certainly we can certainly sell more
than Massachusetts because they tax the
life out of it and I think we can be at
least certainly competitive with Maine
because of the way their tax structure
is if we tax it
for lack of a better way to put it one
time when it leaves the manufacturer on
a on a on a price that we're agreeing
upon just like we do with liquor
they we they give us a they give us
their their cost price we add the retail
markup and we put it out now if it's not
competitive we don't put it out
so we want to work with those
cultivators and manufacturers to make
sure that whatever they're giving us
we're going to be competitive
I hope that answered the question that
was very helpful to me thank you
representative Platt
uh thank you for taking my question and
thank you for allowing me the question
um are you comfortable with a 15 as the
current bill uh
stipulates for tax rate or would you be
happy with something lower
well I certainly think that something
lower would be uh would obviously pass
the uh product along to the consumer at
uh at a better rate if if obviously if
the committee's comfortable at 15 we'll
make it work but if we if we are looking
to
if we're looking to take business just
just as in liquor 50 of our business
comes from cross-border sales from out
of state this is the same thing that
we're looking at here we're looking at
taking that business away from Maine and
Massachusetts and clearly the numbers
that Maine is experiencing and if you go
to those locations in Maine
those license plates are Massachusetts
and New Hampshire plates so our dollars
are now being spent in Maine we'd like
to take some of that back
representative janigan did you have your
hand up
it didn't but I haven't okay I do have a
question
um thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my question
um I'm struggling a little bit with the
connection between so on page 22 line 27
and 28 where it says it's a 15 tax
and then
what representative spilsbury pointed
out in lines 35 and 37 that the
commission can adopt rules I guess the
question is what what's the connection
between the 15 stated here and the fact
that the commission can set rates so I
guess I'm a little confused does that
mean you can change the 15 percent or
how does that work well I think when
when this was set we were looking for
some sort of a base to do the fiscal
numbers off of so I I think that that we
in the rule that certainly can be
represented as 15 base or a 10 base but
we had to have something to kind of set
our our numbers off of our Revenue
numbers so I think that's where the
where the 15 came in
follow-up so you see that as you could
set a base let's say of 10 but you have
to get up to 50 I mean
that that means that at some point has
to be up to 15 based on what we have
right here now it's just that you may
change where that extra five percent
gets charged is that what you're saying
well I I think what we're what we were
trying to say is that it's it's an
unknown
and
we would like to have a base to start
with we certainly don't want to over
over tax it and we don't we certainly
don't want to under tax it one of the
things that some of including Vermont
was the biggest state uh
when they started this out they didn't
have enough product they ran out of
product Mains run out of products
several times we want to make sure that
if we're going to sell sell it we want
to make sure that we have a constant
Supply which which leads us to we want
to make sure that we have our
cultivators in place
and invested in this before we do the
retail piece of it and I think that the
I don't want to get hung up on the 15
because we're certainly flexible on the
number and I think the rules can be
written in a way that allows the Liquor
Commission that flexibility the main
thing I I want everyone to to understand
is that
we will hire a consultant that's in the
bill and someone will come in and and
help us through this but we want to be
able to work with the cultivators and
manufacturers to create a Harmony in
this business much like we've done with
our liquor business so it will be as
successful
so what do you believe that it would be
better to say instead of
um where it talks about 15 she'll be um
is imposed at a rate of 15 percent would
it be better to say is imposed at a
starting rate of 15 because right now
the way that's worded it's it's strong
it's like it doesn't really give you the
capability of modifying it so would you
be happier with a starting rate and I'm
not saying 15 is the rate we'll end up
on but just
sure I'm I'm fine with that absolutely
and Madam chair can I step in to clarify
you can clarify but representatively had
her hand up first for the next question
thank you
right before we move on
the bill as written sets the tax rate at
15 percent
that can't be changed by rulemaking
this committee can propose an amendment
uh you know so it's up for discussion
but once the bill is enacted it's not up
for rulemaking what is commissioner if
you can confirm that I'm right on this
what would be the likely subject of
rulemaking would be how to ascertain the
value of the product upon which the 15
is applied that's correct
yeah so we might need to clarify that
okay in this language just to be clear
yes go ahead and representative and so
just to follow up on that that was
that's a good point that's the point I'm
making here where I didn't believe the
way this is worded that they could
change the percentage and therefore you
know it's a business they want to be
competitive we need to give the ability
to potentially change that rate to be
competitive
representative Leafly thank you for your
patience thank you thank you for taking
my question
um do we tax alcohol right now no okay
it it's hard for me to wrap my mind
around because
we're talking about such different
things here we do get to set the price
on alcohol
um and the
money that the state is taking in is not
a tax right it's we own the state stores
it's the revenue that is transferred to
the general fund that's correct right so
I guess I'm confused about the discourse
of us being able to set prices are we is
the proposal that we will sell
um cannabis products in state stores
where we will control the prices but no
all the stores will be privately owned
okay and the price that I'm talking
about being flexible is the price per
pound at the wholesale level
so that's the price where
that's where there needs to be the
flexibility right so I'm having a hard
time understanding it it seems like I
understand there are two models right we
could sell cannabis products in a state
store like we sell alcohol and there
would be Revenue associated with that it
seems like the other model we're
discussing is we have a free market
and we're taxing uh
product that is deter the value of which
is determined by the market so it it's I
feel like that's what we're talking
about there's the sticky area of what is
the value if we're selling it to
ourselves right if we're vertically
integrated company how do we fairly
determine the value and I think
representative Ames talked about
you know Illinois has written some of
that into the law my question remains
like
at the beginning there's really no known
price and it seems like if we're talking
about if we're comparing it to tobacco
and I think we should because there's a
cost to society with this product right
and I feel like we've in this bill
there's an expectation that we will
generate Revenue which will help address
that cost to society
um so that it's important that we
generate Revenue I believe so that we
can meet the expectations laid out in
the bill but I guess I'm wondering if
we're going to tax something
normally we do that based on a market a
value determined by the market and it
seems like we're kind of stuck on that
wholesale it's going to be tricky to
figure out even if we tax gross receipts
it's if you're selling to yourself and
you're vertically integrated
company it's difficult to determine what
those grocery seats are I think
we want to avoid
um we want to avoid
certain behaviors based on taxation
right we want to avoid people saying oh
well it's only worth X
um so I feel like
I just want to get clear around
letting if we're letting the market
determine price it seems like that's
where the taxation should happen so I'm
happy to have a taxation tax happen at
the wholesale level and at the retail
level but I think it's important that we
acknowledge that this isn't like alcohol
we're not determining the price
representative Bolton did I see your
hand up earlier yeah I think she kind of
nailed it though okay okay
good for now okay other hands
representative I would argue that the
rulemaking that would take place
which is allowed in this legislation
would set the price
and so yeah we are setting the price by
looking at comparable sales elsewhere
where it's not vertically integrated
so that's what the Liquor Commission
just referred to setting the price
okay representative fellows yes
thank you madam chair
um I just want to talk about the
attempting to tax it at the wholesale
level uh let me read to you a quote from
a news report in Michigan on February
14th of this year
and what they write is Michigan's spot
wholesale flower price averaged nearly
two thousand seven hundred fifty dollars
a pound in January of 2001.
and dipped 66 percent to 925 dollars a
pound in October of 2022.
so to add to the complication of
just how you catch it at the wholesale
level
um trying to assume you're going to get
any certain amount of Revenue on that is
going to be particularly difficult and
the one of the suggestions that we were
hearing a little while ago oh from I
think representative Ames was telling us
what another state did in terms of how
they were trying to determine the value
of of wholesale
if if it was integrated they were going
to look at comparable prices uh how
that's like that's it's a commodity
market and the spot price is today is
necessarily nothing like it was a month
or two months ago so any attempt to try
to find some kind of average just I just
totally would not work
and the other thing is to if we were
um trying to get enough Revenue to even
maintain the program in terms of EX in
inspection and Licensing and all that
sort of thing to have
um you know trying to raise a decent
amount of Revenue off something that's
taxed at 50 15 when it's less than
the wholesale price is less than a
thousand dollars a pound is just we're
not going to make any enough Revenue to
make it worthwhile
okay I'm gonna look around on this side
any other hand on this side no
representative Orris okay thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question sir
are we
can we set the price at the liquor store
or do you have to reinvent the wheel in
order to
figure out where you would be at if this
happened in a month or two or
sorry representative can we set the
price on liquor at the liquor store you
set the price on liquor at the liquor
store yeah so my question is can we set
the price on cannabis based on the
market analysis that you're going to do
and that you do do with liquor would you
be able to do the same with cannabis and
keep us competitive and would that be
something that would then generate the
revenue that the liquor does which puts
a lot of money in our general fund well
I I think that the the revenue that
cannabis produces would be a far stretch
to ever say that it would produce the
same thing or even close to the same
thing that liquor produces obviously the
liquor business has been entrenched for
85 years and this is something that's
just starting out the goal the goal of
the idea of how we put it how we put
this into play would be to Simply tax
the product once at a fair market value
to the manufacturers and
The Growers
and then
because the the product would be sold in
private stores this would allow the
people to own those stores to set the
price at retail we wouldn't have
anything to do with setting the price at
retail and that way it truly will allow
the market to speak
the people that sell it at the prices
that are competitive will Thrive and the
people that don't sell it at the prices
that aren't competitive will not the
Liquor Commission doesn't want to have
oversight of the retail price we were
just contemplating setting the price
setting a a rate at the
growing level in the manufacturing level
and then allowing the market to speak so
obviously there's going to be just like
there is in in some other states
there'll be people that
grow at a very small level and make a
comfortable revenue and there'll be
people that grow at a larger level and
make even more money but it doesn't
eliminate anyone from from taking any
piece of the market be it large or small
be it the guy who's got an acre
somewhere or a greenhouse that he isn't
using he can do it if someone wants to
come in and grow at a larger level they
can do that as well we're not hurting
anybody in the manufacturing or the
growing level that was kind of our goal
from the beginning okay follow-up
question please so is the Liquor
Commission not interested in getting
involved with cannabis at a retail level
would you not be interested in
sectioning off part of your liquor store
to handle cannabis or is this something
that the Liquor Commission is just not
interested this is not their policy let
me just correct and and that was a
policy consideration of Prior
legislatures but that is not what this
bill entertains so we have to work
within the constructs of this
what has always been passed all we can
do I think is focus on the tax rate and
just being clear what we're taxing okay
let me rephrase then which tax you think
makes the most sense based on your
experience
well uh from a business standpoint I you
know rate what rate makes what rate or
would it more likely does it fit better
with meal and rooms does it fit better
within the tobacco tax
structure we have now
I think it fits better from a consumer
standpoint within the tobacco tax area
and I think the the way it should be
structured in my humble opinion as the
is that the consumer should never feel
that they are being taxed at whatever
level it is I think it's taxed and the
prices set at the manufacturing and the
and the growing level
and then the market whoever owns those
stores however many retail stores there
ends up being in the state
those individuals that own those stores
can set the price in their particular
store or stores that's the free market
thank you okay lots of hands over here
anyone else yes representative spilsbury
I'm
so representative Orr's
last question someone anticipated mine
but take a little further uh a year ago
this committee approved HB 1598 which
was based on the Enterprise model where
the Liquor Commission would run the
retail operation very much analogous to
the liquor operation we've moved beyond
that and I think this is a much better
model
to rely upon the marketplace
the bill is introduced set the tax on
the basis of the meals and rooms and it
literally piggybacked on the meals and
rooms tax Provisions amending them to
call it the meals uh cannabis and rooms
I think that was
not ideal
and so I think that the Commerce
committee's amendments that have shifted
this to a straight tax on the product
and moved away from the meals and rooms
construct
is good and and I don't think we
particularly want this to be a sales tax
but having said that
I'm perfectly prepared to support
attacks of the nature we have here I'm
still somewhat confused
about exactly at what level and how
we're going to determine the valuation
so several members of the committee have
surfaced the question of transfer
pricing and it is a thorny
issue and certainly the committee will
not be able to resolve how that would be
done and I'm somewhat concerned that
even rulemaking may not really get on
top of it
I think am I right that there are really
three stages at which you could tax
the cultivator
is more analogous to taxing wine on the
basis of taxing the grape when it's
picked at the vineyard
and that strikes me as problematic
the retail final sale is more analogous
to the sales tax and to the meals and
rooms
but isn't there an intermediate point
there and and you've used the word
wholesaler repeatedly
is there not an intermediate point
that is somewhere above the cultivator
and somewhere below the retail and and
by the way I very much like your point
that the purchaser shouldn't feel the
tax what was paid in tax should already
be embedded
well I think that in my understanding of
there is several
folks in business out there
that do they grow the product
they sell the flower one way they take
the byproduct of the plant and create
uh
Edibles from it they create a hash from
it so that could be done simply within
the same manufacturing facility and or
you could much like you have producers
of beer who don't have a bottling line
either someone comes in and cans their
product at their facility or they tank
it out to someone else and they bottle
or can their beer so there's an
opportunity
in in my mind to tax the product when it
leaves that facility in its final form
regardless of if if it's Leaf uh if it's
Bud if it's Edibles if it's hash when
it's in its final form and the value is
put on it that's when the tax is
appropriately laid so just to clarify
that's what you think would be the
cleanest and easiest for the Liquor
Commission to supervise and get right I
think it's the cleanest for everyone and
the manufacturers that I have spoken
with in other states agree it's one time
it's out the door price it's taxed on
what the retailer is going to mark up on
and then the retailer now there's some
retailers that will work on three
percent there's some that want to make
300. then the market speaks as to who is
successful and who is not it's not the
Liquor Commission that makes that
decision
representative all me and then
representative leapley
I just turned it off uh thank you I I
would agree with this idea of taxing the
wholesaler as they sell to the retailer
I think on that that I think is
well it's not what Illinois is doing but
on when we get to that stage we're
talking about on brownies and and sodas
and things like that as well as
the leaf or flower product
and what Illinois
the only Illinois apparently did was it
its cannabis purchase excise tax
says that 20 percent of the purchase
price is
it it's taxed at 20 percent of the
purchase price for cannabis infused
products
and then it's taxed at 10 percent for
low low grade cannabis that is THC under
35 percent
um and at 25 percent of the purchase
price for THC above 35 so they've
they've just done a simple separation of
the the Cannabis products from the leaf
and flower at different potency levels
and we had been asked by the
uh
the people that are worried about the
addictiveness of the product to
um and the effects on people who weren't
used to seeing 40 THC
uh
taking it on that
they'd like to see the higher
THC levels taxed more than the low THC
levels
as a public health measure but on they
did
they we would have to have some kind of
separation of the tax level if we did it
that way
between the infused products they call
them in Illinois the Cannabis products
and the the Royal leaf and flower
so
representatively
my comments not for the Liquor
Commission so if other people have
questions for them I could hold
um so I feel like that gets closer right
like
because I feel like
taxing the flower on a meal that we're
offering in a restaurant doesn't like
that's really far away from the product
and I feel like you know selling a
pastry
that has market value
that makes sense to tax there because
the Market's going to establish the
value of that my concern so I think
we're getting closer to where we should
be taxing the product if we're taxing it
when it's already a product that will be
sold in that form
my concern is that we're still running
into the same problem when we heard from
Prime their question was like how would
we even establish a value whether it's
at the grower or the manufacturer
they know what the the retail value is
if you're not if you're not selling the
manufactured product to a different
retailer than yourself if you are a
manufacturer and you're selling to 20
different people then the price seems
obvious but if that isn't happening I
guess that's my question about
are we
is it clear what the value of the
product is there if it is then great
that's a great place to to put it my
other
um concern is that the customer should
not feel like they're being taxed and I
feel like as a citizen
I don't I want to know what I'm being
taxed
um so I I would disagree with the
premise that we should hide the tax in
the price somehow I feel like it's
important that consumers know that
they're being taxed and know what that
tax rate is
so just to offer a different perspective
on the taxation
I saw representative Bolton yes
I thank you madam chair I might disagree
with that I don't think people really
want to see how much they're being taxed
maybe they they intimately know how much
uh taxes go on the pack of cigarettes
they're buying but
um I think in New Hampshire we shall not
like indicate how much you're being
taxed so
um and I do kind of agree with the fact
that I prefer you know the tax to be not
necessarily at the grower level even
though it seems like the grower is still
in the mix because they're basically in
the statute or in the uh the proposed
bill but you know um my concern also is
on the Growers and there was a comment
earlier I think was made regarding the
fact that we're just going to be
inundated with like multinational or at
least Interstate Growers that are gonna
pretty much destroy any kind of like uh
well Grassroots kind of like growing
situation
I know
I kind of fed you that one but um but I
think in fact I was talking to my
accountant and and she was saying well
they have a side business of uh of
growing vegetables and also I have
greenhouses and they're looking forward
to this bill passing so they can become
a you know a small grower and I really
don't want to necessarily out of the
gate kind of like you know put them out
of business by uh putting more weight on
the on the grower that they just can't
afford to
you know go forward with it but anyway
that's where I'm coming from
representative so given the topic that's
on the table make a quick comment before
going to my point uh yes I I think we
have plenty of analogies uh with the
beer tax the tobacco tax the gas tax uh
where an excise tax is embedded in an
intermediate level as distinct from a
sales tax so I'm comfortable with this
uh the conversation has
caused me to look more closely
at the tax provision which again is page
lines 27 and 28
and specifically it says
total gross revenue of licensed cannabis
cultivation facilities
so we're each getting sort of drawn
along here in Commodities we learned I
went back and I looked at the definition
of cannabis cultivation facility and
it's broader than cultivator
it says
that that cannabis cultivation facility
means an entity registered to cultivate
prepare and package cannabis
and sell cannabis to retail Cannabis
stores
the Cannabis product manufacturing
facilities to alternate treatment
centers into other cannabis cult
cultivation facilities but not to
Consumers
so I think I've now discovered
that the Bill's in the right place
already
this is the wholesaler
representative plett and then
representative Olney I wanted to make
certain I understand what you just said
even though we've been talk talking
about it at a cultivator level this is
really an existributor level then the
way it's written
yes that's exactly the way I read the
definition of the
cultivation facility
I'm sorry representative could we just I
saw some
facial expressions over here I just want
to see can you just confirm are we going
along the right thinking here to help us
understand
I think you're spot on okay thank you I
saw the smile there representative
yes the last sentence of that section is
a can
of accountability shall not produce
cannabis concentrates tinctures extracts
or other cannabis products
on
and so it is
anything of that nature is going to go
through the Cannabis production
facilities
and the the large businesses that are
going to be uh coming into the market
on with large greenhouses and
Manufacturing attacks attached and I
don't know if it's legal I would prefer
that it wasn't that that they can own
the retailer
stores as well except for samples or
something
but on
they are
they are going to be the majority of
this
this does allow small bits small farmers
with small greenhouses to sell directly
to the retail
but
it just economically
most of them are going most of the stuff
is going to be coming out of very large
greenhouses that cost quite a bit of
capital to set up
okay
commissioner can you weigh in on this
did you study this at all is this going
to be hurting our local farmers do you
have any thoughts on that well I'll use
the analogy of uh independent Brewers
10 years ago there wasn't an independent
Brewer
license and now we have many
people that Brew
beer and sell it into the market because
there's a consumer demand for it so if
these small manufacturers can produce
something that's unique
then they're going to they'll be setting
their Market themselves if they can
produce a flower that's different a
product that's different a Tincher
that's different a wax that's different
that's where they're going to thrive
they're not going to try to compete I
wouldn't think
you know
able Ebenezer doesn't try to compete
with Budweiser it's it's two different
markets they each have their own Market
they each are making money but they're
it's two different markets so I think
that that's that's kind of my analogy of
how people that are in the market that
are small Growers and or manufacturers
can can compete because they're creating
something that's unique
that's a Hands Up Now representative of
rochefort yes thank you madam chair so
you said something a minute ago earlier
in your testimony that
kind of maybe spoke will speak to this
and and
reaffirm what you just said and I want
to make sure I got it right
um
you said that seven there are 75
cultivators in Maine
did I get that right
so I'm assuming with 75 cultivators you
have a mix of
everything from Big agribusiness to I'm
assuming anyway because I can't imagine
there's 75 agribusiness large-scale uh
and then all the way to the other end is
niche special
flower grower I mean I don't know the
industry but I'm sure that some guy can
cultivate a pretty beautiful looking
flower and that's probably what you have
uh everything in in in everything in
between so
hearing that you know in Maine which
next door I
my when we were initially started this
conversation I was concerned about a
supply and issue that we wouldn't be
able to meet a supply or there wouldn't
be anybody that would be willing to take
that risk
but it sounds like the demand is there
especially next door
that would
Prevail and allow us to a variety of
producers then is that I mean is that
dude would you it sounds like you would
hold to that absolutely and and in
speaking with the folks that I've many
folks that I've spoke with in Maine the
cautionary pieces make sure that you
have the manufacturing in place and
those growers in place prior to opening
the retail because the last thing you
want to do is to open retail and not
have enough product so that you need a
plethora of
Manufacturers big and small in order to
to keep the market whole and full and
especially where if we're going to draw
on the model that the Liquor Commission
uses for its revenues we're going to
take some of that revenue from outside
of the state
and our goal is to make sure that the
manufacturing is in place both large and
small prior to retail
thank you that's exactly thank you very
much thank you representative fellows
thank you
um I'm I just
um I appreciate that the commissioner
has done some research on this and it
does make sense to look at the states
that are around us but Maine
um has only had
two
full years of sales and one of the
things I've read repeatedly about the
when a state starts
in the legalizes cannabis and it starts
to be sold is that there's not enough
product available for the first couple
of years and then by the time you get to
about year three the cultivators have
perfected their their process and
they've expanded their crops and then
there is an overload of cannabis
available and the price comes down
I'm one of the things that I'm taking
into consideration here is exactly how
much money we're going to bring into the
state
and so I don't think
that main I well I put it this way I've
been focusing
um looking at the ones that have it at
least three full years of data available
for the sales and the prices come down
and we're proposing to do a tax
that's way below what any of the other
states are doing
the states that I've looked at two of
them did have do have a wholesale tax
but they also have a retail tax so they
have those two taxes combined
and one consideration is compared to the
retail value how much of that value is
coming from the price of the product
that goes in there and and I don't I
just think you know if you assume
something like half and you tax it at 15
percent and the price of that cannabis
is under a thousand dollars a pound
we're not going to make hardly any money
and you know maybe we're going to cover
your inspectors and the management of
the program but we're not going to make
any significant amount of money to go
and either reduce the unfunded liability
in the
um retirement system or school funding
and so I think that we need to give some
consideration to how much money can be
raised from this
I mean it's it's great I'm have no
problem with like you know
creating new business opportunities
but this is a big operation it has
social consequences and we should be
looking at the whole picture thank you
I'm just going to keep scanning around
this side no representative did you have
something
I do thank you madam chair
my question is
in the case where you have a vertically
integrated company where they
they cultivate they manufacture and
they're the retail operation how do you
have you looked into how you would
assess a tax in that case because now
it's not one company selling wholesale
to another company it's a vertically
integrated
system how how would you propose going
about that
the tax whatever it is would be based on
the retail price so if a company is
growing and Manufacturing when the
product leaves either either segment of
the business
the product would be taxed on the retail
value
so obviously hash doesn't weigh that
much or you know or edibles it's it's
based on the value of that product
so you're not doing that by the pound
obviously you know you're doing flour by
the pound or Leaf by the pound or
whatever those products are by the pound
and or ounce whatever however it ends up
but the the dollars that the state will
make are based on the retail value of
that product and just like any other
business I mean we have we'll have
Auditors in place and we will have
inspectors in place this product when
it's
it's given a skew number at the seed
level so there's no sneaking one by the
goalie it doesn't happen because the
product starts with a with a seed and a
skew and that follows the product all
the way through the sale
follow-up um
okay so then in a case where you have a
wholesaler who sells it to a different
retailer
where does the tax come in then is that
that retailer that will
pay the tax
because the the difference there is
if you have a vertically integrated
Market
who sells retail
that price is going to be presumably
higher than the person who's wholesaling
it to another retail because now they're
paying the tax on the wholesale price
you see what I'm saying
I think I do but I you know the
Safeguard for us in this idea was to
make it simple and to tax it once so
it's taxed at the value when it leaves
the manufacturing facility or the
growing facility it's taxed at that
level if somebody then transfers it to
somebody else and sells it
tax is already paid if someone else
wants to if someone's willing to pay I
think it would be a pretty
not not well thought out business idea
to be able to take it and sell it to
somebody else and then try to make a
markup that's where I said I I think
that we have to allow the business
people who are out there that are in
this business to make those decisions
about how they'll buy and sell the
product and if they make uh
if they make decisions that are
not amenable to their the success of
their business then that falls on their
shoulders
representative Madam chair we've been an
hour and 15 minutes or so discussing
essential what tax level that should be
taxed at and what I heard is that we
really are doing at a distributor level
because of the wording and the bill I
wonder if we could start going through
our brahmi comments and mark up the bill
and come at the end to whether we think
we need changes as to the level and the
rate
representative
if you thank you
Madam chair
short question
and we understand what purview of this
committee to talk about these things
that we're talking about
how much how much of this that you've
been expressing today if anything was
brought forward in the Commerce
Committee in the original hearing of the
bill just just a question
all of it
when we discussed it with Commerce I'm
the policy committee did the deep deep
dive on this
um and we're supposed to be focusing
very narrowly on what we're doing here
representative Doucet
thank you madam chair as I told you
earlier I addressed some some of uh
uh The Honorable Pat abrami's technical
defects that he saw I didn't address any
what I saw as policy issues in the
handout he gave us and I have a draft
Amendment if if we can work off of that
so did you want to pass that out now
certainly okay included included in that
as a okay I see a bunch of hands up
we'll keep going with the hands but um
yeah at some point it would be nice if
we can get to some sort of consensus on
this section of our discussion before we
move on but representative spilsbury and
then we'll go down and then we'll Circle
back around
sure I I think there's a level of
confusion that's sort of arisen back
into the conversation in the last few
minutes uh when I thought we had gotten
clear uh and perhaps that's just you
know verbal looseness uh but you
mentioned uh commissioner uh the retail
term
and and yet I thought we were sort of
you know coming into the conclusion that
there's a culture for a cultivator
wholesale retail
cultivator and wholesale May coincide at
times they may diverge at times
and so representative Ami pointed to the
last sentence of the Cannabis
cultivation facility definition that's
page three
final two lines 36 and 37 page three
page three definitions
cannabis cultivation facility is defined
lines 33 to 37. so certainly there are
value added
steps that can be taken in the
manufacturing process
to create variants using the TLC product
such as concentrates tinctures extracts
and so on
and I believe that that is incorporated
into the definition that's found over on
the next page for
lines four to seven
of a cannabis product manufacturing
facility
cannabis product manufacturing facility
definition is very parallel
to cannabis cultivation facility
in that in both cases it says
you know manufacturing prepare package
these are similar in overlapping terms
and cell cannabis and cannabis products
to other cannabis product manufacturing
facilities alternative treatment centers
to retail Cannabis stores but not to
Consumers now I understand that there's
a need to define the two different terms
I understand there's overlap
my question is
then when we go back to page 22
and we Define what this 15 tax applies
to
we use only the term cannabis
cultivation facilities
should we be adding
cannabis product manufacturing facility
is that not also the wholesaler for
certain variants of the product
the tax should be applied at any time
the product is leaving a manufacturing
facility in any form
so given that
I would think we would want to amend
the language on page 22 line 27 and 28
to insert after cannabis cultivation
facilities
the phrase
or cannabis product manufacturing
facility and that would Cover the
Waterfront
consistent I believe with what you've
explained
does that sound right
I'd agree
I the only thing I would add if there's
if there's other deficiencies in the
language I just want to be certain that
whenever the product leaves whether it's
a three thousand dollar pound of flour
or a ten dollar brownie yes it's taxed
at that number once one time so perhaps
we use the term either or because we
don't want to apply two-point taxation
correct thank you
okay we're going to keep going down this
side and then we'll come swing back
around representative Leafly
so just so we can continue Along on this
this
um think through of this part of the
bill it seems like you would never want
to
have the tax fall on the brownie right
if you're someone who wants to make
money obviously you would be paying a
lot more money on a manufactured
finished product that's ready to go to
retail
so it seems like
by definition you would be setting up
the
the industry to tax at the
to tax a cultivator let me just but
isn't right the tax based on the value
they've already decided on
who is they the market no the liquor
Liquor Commission so the Liquor
Commission is setting the price
oh they're setting the value the excise
tax value
the value which upon the excise tax will
be charged am I correct correct me if
I'm wrong thank you okay can can we
pause here so is the excise tax the 15
percent
my question is
you would if you're involved in this
industry
you would not be interested in paying a
tax on a brownie that is going to sell
for ten dollars right you don't want to
pay 15 on ten dollars
if you could pay
a much smaller rate
of attacks pre-manufacturing
the price wouldn't be tempting would you
care to comment or clarify
if you could pay if if I'm selling if
I'm in the market of selling cakes
if I could pay my taxes on the flower
that is valued lower than my pastry I
would pay the taxes on the flower I
would never choose to pay the taxes on
the pastry right so I guess my question
is when we write a bill that says you
can pay 15 percent on the flower or on
the on the pastry the finished pastry
there would be no interest in paying it
on the finished pastry right
I'm just trying to think through what
what this looks like in the industry out
in the wild let me just see if the
commissioner has anything to say and
then we'll go around and keep going
around the room thank you anything to
comment or clarify
at this point okay representative
elberger I've got a couple of questions
and I'm feeling like I'm more confused
now than I was at the beginning
um at the bottom of page three
it says a cannabis cultivation facility
shall not
produce cannabis concentrates tinctures
extracts or other cannabis products
and yet we're talking on page 22
about cannabis cultivation facilities
can do all those things
so I'm wondering about why it says on
one page shall not and on another page
it says it's fine
no where does it say that on kitchen 22.
yeah
um
line 27 and on page three
36 shall not
no
it doesn't say it
representative Orr thank you madam chair
so I'm sorry can I get an answer to that
that was the point
of adding the second definition
of a cannabis
um
what's our terms product manufacturing
facility why are we leaving that not
then
on page not just take it out
to avoid anybody's confusion
right
but I think they're performing two
different roles in the chain of the
market production
s came from a lot that working group
that met over the last year to really
understand the industry
um so I think it came from that deep
dive of understanding I I appreciate the
work
I think that a typical human being
seeing on this page shall not will
assume it means shall not
maybe I can lessen the confusion here
what the my my interpretation of what
the cultivator does is from seed to
flower okay in this instance and what
the production component the next
component of that would be taking that
flower taking that product grown from
seed by the cultivators and turning it
into what you reference the brownie or a
tincture or a topical or or what have
you so they're two distinct different
processes one one is the grower and one
is the person that produces what the
retail and the third
uh Link in the chain would sell retail
if if that helps that's my understanding
anyway
I'm sorry it doesn't because we're using
the exact same term
cultivation facility representative orrs
thank you madam chair so the help rep
representative alberger I think the
answer is this this still needs work
last week we talked about taxing at the
distributor level I started to touch on
that today representative spilsberry
gave us the answer
at the distributor lever level level The
Liquor Commission has given us the
answer at the distributor level we need
to get the wording straight on this when
I went online I couldn't believe the
products I saw I did some research over
the weekend hard to believe but I
actually did that because the weather
was nice and anyways I try them out was
what
did you try them out
it was virtual
but my point is I couldn't believe it
was everything is out there cookies
chocolate chip cookies chocolates
infused drinks gummy bears they actually
are gummy bears out there and gummy
products and if there was anything you
can think of
it's there a cup of coffee infused with
cannabis I think the Liquor Commission
and the Brilliance of their experience
says you have to tax it at the level the
how did he put it you're going to tax
the products in final form that's just
what we've been talking about we're kind
of dancing around it it's whatever that
retail value is whether it's a cookie
lollipop a gummy a chocolate a beverage
hash flour edible it all makes sense to
tax it at whatever the retail value is
at that time and then
as the Liquor Commission is stated
let the let the private Distributors
that are selling it figure out whether
it's I think he said three percent you
know profit margin or 300 percent and
that'll that'll level the playing field
as a who's right and who's wrong and as
rep elberger just mentioned I mean she's
absolutely right there's some
conflicting words in here whether we
change it on page 22 as reps billsberry
said about cannabis manufacturing
facility in the final form
this needs to work we have the answer I
believe it's it's been it's been
verified and given to us from The Liquor
Commission it's at this level whatever
it is in final form whatever the product
is in final form that's where you apply
to tax and as it's been mentioned over
here
nobody's going to really know about
except for the fact that representative
Jason Osborne was on WMUR over the
weekend and said we're creating new tech
so everybody knows we're creating new
tax don't worry about it thank you all
right I'm just gonna and try to be fair
and just keep going around the room in a
circular fashion representative fellows
seems to me there's only one solution to
this if you want to tax it if you want
to raise revenue
if you want to collect state revenue at
the
at the cultivator level or wholesale
level I think people when they I think
they're using those two terms
interchangeably the only way to do it is
to set a fixed amount so much per ounce
is going to be the I don't even know if
you call it a tax or you call it a
whatever you want to call it I guess I
guess you can say attacks so much per
ounce and I think that you'd probably
want to make a distinction between the
flowers and the leaves because I did see
not in too many places but I did see
that um there's some states make a
distinction between those two that's the
only way to keep it that works for the
integrator it works for the cultivator
um
that's the only thing that would work
it just turned itself off and I've had
it on forever on I would like to propose
I don't I'm not talking about the tax
rate part of it but on page 22 line 27
that we change that to a tax on the
monthly total gross revenue of licensed
uh
cannabis facilities when selling
directly to the retailer
that is the real wholesale level and it
doesn't get into how many ounces are in
a brownie it gets into what the
Brownie's worth with the stuff in it
okay going back this way did I just add
to that since I have uh we we are the
tax committee
anything to do with taxes inside of this
whole document we can change and we
should change if we think that it's not
working as well
and we need to get all of that clear
before we go into to amendments I think
thank you representative I agree with
representative Almy
I also agree with representative
elberger get rid of that shell not up
front because we're allowing it to be a
cultivator or a manufacturer and we're
taxing it at the retail level
essentially as it goes to the retailer
and so it's it's clear that it's a as as
the commissioner already said it's at a
manufacturer level or a cultivated level
which whichever is going directly to
Consumers
representative spillsbury nothing over
here representative Spielberg
uh I think we understand the nature of
the issue at this point and I would be
willing to undertake to put some
language together for a review next
Monday
defining as closely as possible that
it's the final form at the wholesale
level
okay we're just going to keep moving
right or wrong and then once we get
through this cycle I need to leave for
another meeting and representative
janigan will take over and make sure we
get through this representative Doucet
thank and I think representative
spilsberry and representative almie are
on the same page it's just a matter of
language agreeing to the language
because I think either or can be covered
but to representative fellows comment
the the commissioner the commission will
set what the market price is and and an
example that you gave was uh tax again
at a certain ounce and we've heard
testimony that there are certain
concentration levels there's certain
quality levels there's uh
my Ferrari is going to be taxed at a
higher rate than my Hyundai okay and and
that that's the case the THC content in
this product
can be grown and cultivated to be at a
higher level
depending on the strain from the from
the testimony that I've heard okay which
makes it a more valuable a more
profitable a a higher uh Market
price
and they would tax it at that market
price so I don't know that whether the
weight of measure matters or not but I I
have great confidence that they'll
they'll navigate that but I I don't
think we can just put put a one ounce
thing on it has to be the market price
that may be something we could further
clarify when we give them rulemaking
Authority the types of things we'd like
them to consider as part of their rule
making on that anyway representative
Leafly thank you so again I thought it
was clear and now I'm confused
um so I thought we were talking about a
15 tax and we are trying to figure out
where to put it right how do we get at
the value of the product
um if we're also going to be adding
we're just giving the Liquor Commission
authority to add additional taxes I'm
not clear on that
no I I believe that I'm speaking very
much in alignment with your comments
of 15 with some language to help The
Liquor Commission uh establish rules as
to what exactly they're taxing
and we will have that language
so I'm referring to
um
representative doucet's comments about
ounces and THC value
my thinking is that again the market and
I would say we should tax the retail
value of the product because it's the
clearest thing it the market will decide
the value of something based on a number
of factors because consumers are so
Savvy right they're going to look at a
product and they're going to consider
the THC value they're going to consider
the ounces they're going to consider the
need that their
you know meeting with the purchase of
the product so it seems to me that the
clearest easiest
way to do it is a 15 tax on the retail
value because again I still see this
problem if you're vertically integrated
like the man from Prime who came and
said you know we grow
the stuff we manufacture the product and
then we sell it at the retail value and
sure he can like break those into three
separate businesses right the
cultivating business the manufacturing
business the retail business
but what are you selling that to
yourself at is unclear to him today
but the price of that gummy being sold
to a consumer is Crystal Clear to him
and so taxing it there we don't The
Liquor Commission wouldn't need to have
a conversation about THC levels the
consumer is going to
establish the value of the product and I
think that also addresses your concern
about Revenue generation if we're taxing
the bud as it comes off the plant
there's a whole bunch of value added
that you're missing out on taxing so I
feel like it's the cleanest but I am
feel like we are getting a lot closer to
zeroing in on this thank you
why do you feel like we're getting
closer that's representative Spielberg
yeah just just to respond
um so let's keep
some different things separate
I think that representative Doucet was
effectively addressing
what's problematic
about taxing on the basis of weight
and there are other parameters the
beauty of taxing on price
is that price makes all variables
into the pie right so I think that you
and I representative Ami and others are
in agreement
that we're better off
taxing value
you're making a case
for taxing at the retail level which is
more like a sales tax
and the
basically the discussion is now boiled
down to I think
if we can all agree we want a tax value
will it be at the wholesale level or
will it include the Retailer's markup
the wholesale level as has been
explained by the commissioner
is intended to be where the product has
reached its final form
but has not yet
at a retail markup
if we can craft language that would
capture that thought
it strikes me we would have a clear
majority of the committee would you go
along with it I agree
could I respond to that I feel like
we're getting so close so
probably
um because the only problem I have with
the wholesale is that how do we actually
know that's the value whereas the retail
Market we know that's the value because
somebody's buying it somebody who's not
yourself right
um but the other little piece I want to
add is I feel like there's a concern
that it's too like a sales tax which I
think is a valid concern here in New
Hampshire I get it but I think we all
agree we would not be taxing this
product if it weren't regular product
right it's not a sales tax it is a tax
on a drug right it is a tax on a drug
that is currently illegal in New
Hampshire so the reason we want to tax
it is not because it's being sold and we
want to profit from the sale of a
product right as if it were a shirt or a
carton of milk it's not a sales tax
right just because we're we're letting
letting the market determine the value
of the product it's not a sales tax it's
not creeping into we're going to tax
everything it's
this we want to tax it for the same
reason that we control alcohol sales and
that we tax tobacco in the state so I
think it would be more appropriate to
call it you know a cannabis tax because
that's what we want to tax here we don't
want to tax a sale
so I understand the concern about
placing that tax at the retail
um level but if that's the best place
that's the best place
yes representative
thank you I agree with you by the way it
makes sense in the same way that
if you're selling cakes and I'm selling
cakes
we set the price of our cakes and people
buy the cake that they want but
one of the questions to shift gears a
minute
we're looking at as far as I can tell
dealing with
producers and manufacturers here in New
Hampshire
well we know that we have craft beers
produced here in New Hampshire and as
you pointed out we also have liquor
products that are made somewhere else
and brought in here
how are we dealing with products that
are not made in new not grown here if
somebody in Massachusetts or Hawaii has
a wonderful niche
strain of marijuana and people want to
bring it in here how are we taxing them
are we going back to Hawaii and taxing
years get anything from Hawaii it's
forbidden by the federal it's it was an
example it's illegal today
right or Massachusetts it's illegal
today but the whole the whole question
that we talked about the other day is we
don't know how long it's going to be
illegal if we put it on the retail
product today and tomorrow it becomes
legal to import from Maine or Vermont or
South Dakota
we won't have to revisit this bill and
lose Revenue in the meantime because
we're not taxing imports from South
Dakota we will be all set right
okay let me uh come over the side and
then we'll come back to representative
Colette representative Ames
yeah
yeah I I just wanted to uh
back up what you just said I think that
um
that we are moving in a good direction
here
um but that the retail level is what
works in a environment where the
cross-border
restriction is no longer operative
um and um
it works for all the other reasons that
representative Leafly and others have uh
have uh spoken to it's a better level to
work to to uh to come down at
in if we're going to look at the long
term and we I think we all think that
eventually and it may be sooner than
later
the federal restriction that um
by perception or by
by law however you want to view it is
operative right now and and preventing
interstate
sales or transfers of product will go
away and if it goes away then the retail
level is the level that works otherwise
you miss a lot of things so I just
wanted to reinforce what has been said
on that point
foreign
yes on
we
compete The Liquor Commission come
across
a fairly large region of the Northeast
despite the fact that legally they're
not supposed to be moving liquor back
and forth across the border uh
and what I would like to do is to use
whatever language you've got on that
allows you to set these the prices in
The Liquor Commission
on if we could use that
together with the idea of taxing at the
level whatever level sells directly to
the retailer
but I don't I it occurs to me that I've
never thought about
um they that you're an Enterprise this
would not be an Enterprise I take it so
so perhaps on
it would require that which would be
quite a change in the structure
can you comment on that
well if the commission is thicker in
cannabis then we certainly would would
be covered we collect the beer tax now
as well and uh
to the statement of products that that
is being sold out of state in the Liquor
Commission we we had a letter from the
IRS that was written to to us that
clearly defined the ability to for the
Liquor Commission to sell product
and not require if someone buys product
outside of the state that they're in
it's their responsibility to pay the tax
in the state that they live in yeah so
uh the language that allows us to
to set price is in in statute and those
uh variances are set in statute as well
so what would we need to stick in thank
you stick in here
to give you that same
ability I think
the discussion that's taken place to tax
the product at the retail value is
exactly what we've been speaking to
there's a value because of the great
differentiation of value of each product
that's where the state can make the
largest amount of Revenue and it's very
fair for the grower and manufacturer and
it's also very profitable for the state
I I think that
depending on how you
finalize what's written I think that
that we're certainly on track to what we
our general idea was when we started out
with the language
representative Platt
my initial understanding of this bill
was that it's strictly at a cultivated
level but at the discussion of the
wording it's clear it's a distributor
level not a cultivated level
and that's fine there's some recent uh
argument for a retail level
is sort of a distributor level
distributor level works like the beer we
tax at a distributor level and it works
fine the retail level is a it's more
akin to a sales tax but we call them
something different I I'm not falling on
my sword for uh retail level I think
distributed level will work but what
what won't work is 15 because there's a
whole bunch of added value at a
manufacturer level than it was right
straight off the farm essentially and so
I point out that uh representative uh
to sets Bill Amendment here drops it to
eight percent and we should have a
discussion about what's an appropriate
rate
all right we'll uh we'll get there in a
minute let me just get to uh
representative
put your microphone on please oh could
we ask the commissioner to explain the
beer tax and how we collect that and how
it goes through a warehouse and
let me uh it's just so people understand
what sure let me just get to
representative ulery first thank you
representative fellows for taking my
question
oh wow
yes what she said except explain both
how you set the value or it's really not
setting the value but it's setting your
your cost uh basis for taxation purposes
and how uh you take the beer out of
Merrimack and it goes into a bonded
facility and all that yes that needs to
be explained to everyone because they
don't understand how it operates and I'm
presuming that based upon the language
in here
based upon the language on here a
similar type of bonding or regulated
transfer for of uh product will take
place
if I'm not incorrect please
elucidate thank you sir
well the tax on the beer is done on per
gallon so it's 30 cents a gallon
30 cents a gallon at Manufacturing
regardless of the cost to sell it that's
correct and the similar type of activity
takes place with the marijuana bill
correct
no
the the
way the idea that we had in mind as I've
said if
the value of a pound of flour
is three thousand dollars now you can
use the terminology at wholesale or at
retail it's irrelevant my ma in my mind
if a brownie is going to sell for ten
dollars
you pay the fifteen percent on the ten
dollars if if a if a pound of flour is
going to sell for thirty eight hundred
dollars you pay the tax on that that way
the tax is paid once and it's paid
through
follow-up okay that that
makes perfect sense to me the only
question is
if we're basing this on a value who sets
the value
but we could have it the market sets the
value if the market as I said the the
market the dollar value of the flower or
the anything will will fluctuate
I I don't think that will be the same
with manufactured products
follow-up
Okay so
a brownie is going to a brownie is going
to cost
750.
I bought them recently I I mean 10 bucks
all right that's the LSU is 10 bucks
it's just a round number if the brownie
costs 10 bucks and it takes
two ounces of flour to make that brownie
plus other ingredients
the value of two ounces of flour then is
how much
so that you can figure out what a pound
of flour costs
when it's produced well
my understanding of the process is the
flower would wouldn't be used in the
manufacturing of an edible it's a
byproduct the flour is of such value
that it's sold at flower level only the
Edibles are made from the byproduct the
trim from the plant itself so you
the
the value of the tax is at the at the
price of the product if someone it costs
somebody 25 dollars to bake their cake
and they want to sell it for 25 that's a
business decision if I'm a businessman I
want my cake to cost me ten dollars and
sell it for 25. that's a manufacturing
and or uh growing level decision but the
question that seems to be bugging a
bunch of people
here is how does that that sale price
connect with the value or apportioned by
the agency on the product for taxation
purposes well I think just like anything
that you you do in business you're going
to be in concert effort with those
manufacturers and and Growers so that
price will be set according to the
market if somebody's if somebody says to
me the manufacturer knows how much money
they want to make on their brownie if
the retail on the brownie is ten dollars
and it costs them five dollars to make
they're comfortable with that so some
might not be but it's irrelevant of how
in my mind how you get to the price of
of what it costs them to make it the
most important piece is we're taxing at
the retail dollars so if some to go back
to the flower the you know the flour and
baking the cake initiative uh to me it's
it's irrelevant
if you want to put a a pound of of X in
your cake and the THC level is higher I
think as a manufacturer you're a
business person you're going to say it
cost me this much to make this I have to
charge this much to sell it
so those are decisions that are that are
made at a at a growing and Manufacturing
level the value of of what it costs to
make someone wouldn't be in business if
they put x amount in there in in this
particular product to not make a profit
I understand what you're saying okay
I don't see how you can figure out a
subjective
excuse me an objective
pricing level
on that
scenario there has
if you're saying that the market sets
the price of the flower or the grain or
the bag or you know whatever and I you
hear all these reports about X number of
dollars worth of uh marijuana being
captured coming across the Arizona
border
who sets that price where does it come
from
and I think that is the question that a
lot of people are trying to get their
their their
well two fingers on ah
did you want did you have a follow-up to
that okay uh representative balmy
could you explain what you mean by the
retail price
the way I'm listening to it I think that
what you're talking about is what
they plan to sell it to the retailer for
now the retail price in my mind would
would be what the retailer is charging
so we'd be taxing that
that assumption even though you expect
the retailers to all be selling at
different prices well I I think just
like any business there will be people
selling product at different prices and
to me it the discussion this was enough
this was the idea that we had that in
order for the state to maximize the
revenue that they were going to get
regardless of how the product obviously
there's going to be rules and
regulations on how the product is
manufactured and the THC level that is
that's for the manufacturers and Growers
to take into effect
but in in our minds If the product is
going to be sold for x amount of dollars
we want to tax it at the highest
possible level so in order to tax it at
the retail level whatever the price if
that product is going to be in someone's
case in their store at ten dollars that
that dollar fifty has already been paid
at 15 percent that dollar fifty tax has
already been paid at that level
how can the
on manufacturer know what the retailer
is going to charge well
when he transfers it over unless he is
the retailer the man the manufacturer we
would set the price of that product
whatever it's going to be I mean
obviously there's going to be if you're
going to sell we'll go back to alcohol
if you're selling alcohol that's a
hundred proof it has a higher value than
a alcohol that's at 80 proof so these
are these are all the gyrations that
will have to be taken into consideration
in rule making I mean nothing is set in
stone as far as the idea of how we'd
like to do it yeah I think that's that's
a good point I think part of the maybe
part of the confusion here is that in
rulemaking many of these uh product
levels
um you know how much THC is in a product
and so forth that's where the value will
be set and that's where the tax will be
upon I think I'm getting the sense that
people are thinking too much about a
finished product like a brownie or a
gummy I don't know what all the
different products are but it it's more
about what is the content of these
things my understanding is that
basically what you're saying
well yes and and there's it's kind of
two-fold because I also think that the
manufacturer when we buy a bottle of rum
we'll buy a bottle of Bacardi we know in
the market what it will sell for not
only in our Market but in the markets
around us as a business person we're
certainly not we don't want to sell it
for for more because we're not going to
we're not going to move the product we
don't want to sell it for too little
because then we're not going to make the
profit so there's that sweet spot where
you attract people to buy your product
and the price is competitive
do you have a follow-up yes I still
don't quite understand are you going to
tax
each route basically tax the retailers
but somehow do it at the wholesaler
level on tax them on the basis of what
they're charging in their store or are
you going to go through
what usually the price usually is of
that particular item across several
states to start with and then and then
tax at that level
the the for the retail price the product
will be taxed at the finished product at
the retail price the manuf the retailer
pays will pay no tax because for lack of
a better way to put it the tax is
already baked in to the brownie the tax
is already it's already there with the
price of the pound of flour so the
manufacturer says this pound of flour at
retail is thirty eight hundred dollars
you add the fifteen percent to that
number this pound of flour is twelve
hundred dollars you add the fifteen
percent to that this bag of Edibles is
15. you add the tax to that this
particular uh edible is only ten so
that's how
so you're not charging the markup you're
charging this on the cost of production
oh there's no markup on the liquor
commissions part it's strictly whatever
tax you decide will be added at the
finished product level as it moves to
retail
so for that number at retail that's what
we're going to that's what the idea was
to tax at that number
okay representative spilsbury
uh so I think the entire range of our
discussion can be boiled down to whether
we're taxing on the value the retailer
pays
or whether it includes the Retailer's
markup
so that's a decision for the committee
I just want to point out to go back to
conversation 10 minutes ago or so
the question about what evolves on the
federal level
and whether we've structured attacks
that is prepared for interstate commerce
the answer is it doesn't make a
difference whether it's the wholesale or
the retail level in both cases it works
for an imported product so I think we've
Allied that concern
uh representative
Alberta thank you
um I think the notion of a retail price
is
quite unrealistic
um
a retailer is selling based on
per or his costs somebody who has a shop
in Nashua is paying high higher costs
for their real estate than someone who
is who has a shop in Berlin just because
the cost of real estate is higher
so I I have a very hard time with the
notion of a consistent
retail price here and quite honestly I
think
that the most
logical in my mind way to go is to set
it as a retail price to the consumer
I just want to ask a clarifying question
I mean we're I think we're still getting
in the weeds of a of specific retail
products and how much they're worth
versus
the value of the components aren't we
really talking about the value of the
components
because you
representative maybe I can offer an
analogy here as simple as it may
and and we we could sit and talk about a
sales tax or whatever label you want to
put on it okay but but the fact remains
is we have to entrust the Commission in
in coupling what the market value of a
product is at when we come to the
language that we need to at the
cultivation and or production level
it's it's common sense to know that
there's going to be differing price
points whether it's per ounce per pound
you need to measure we shouldn't we
shouldn't get into that what we should
get into is what what the retail sale
what and we keep into changing retail
and wholesale and forgive me for doing
that
what we need to do is say we have a uh a
silk shirt made by Versace
and I have a Fruit of the Loom canvas
t-shirt two two T-shirts one of them is
worth a little more than the other I
have to have faith in the commission and
whomever he assigns or whatever division
they assign to to give that price that
that market value and we tax on that
market value at the level that the the
uh silkworms are spinning it or at the
level of the Craftsman that put the
shirts together and we'll have to Cobble
that language together but the fact
remains is we have to have faith that
somebody has to set what market value is
we all know what our houses are worth we
all know what our shoes are worth and on
and on and on so we can go around and
around in circles but we somebody has to
set it and and I have great faith that
the commission will couple with What's
Done in rules we'll figure that out
we'll navigate that okay let me ask you
a question then representative you said
so they will in the rules they'll have
prices for different retail products now
if a retailer wants to sell it at
50 more than that go ahead and do it but
that's the point but the tax will be
paid on representative that's the point
we're getting in way into the minutia it
has nothing to do with what a retailer
sells right his price point if if I
decide to do business in Berlin New
Hampshire or Nash we're using using the
example the representative just did
that's that's my decision as a business
owner okay and I know it's going to cost
me a little less for rent a little more
to heat and and so on a little less
traffic in Berlin as opposed to
Nashville that's not the point the point
is what's the value of the commodity no
matter what the commodity is the market
value of the commodity going forward we
have to allow for them to set that bar
comparing it whatever metrics they use
to set that value okay as approved
through rules
they set the mark
they charge up whatever the tax is at
the end at at that level
and
you know I'm just trying to simplify it
a little bit yeah
thank you uh representative bleepley
thank you I have two I have a comment
and then a question so my comment would
be that what sets the market value
is the market it's not a government
agency
so I think there's no way that a
government agency can dynamically guess
what the market value is for something
and
like that's a capitalist system and
we've agreed that we want
this to be sold on the open market by
retailers that are overseeing and
regulated and not have the commission
sell
um cannabis like they sell alcohol so
it's my understanding that the market is
setting the value of the product which
will be crystal clear at the retail
store you'll walk in and you'll see what
the value of things are if the silk
shirt is something that's more desirable
than the canvas shirt people will be
willing to pay more for it so that's my
first comment is that I think we have to
acknowledge that the way that we've
there are other ways to do it but the
way that we're talking about
taxing this product is based on the
market value and the market is the best
way to establish that my question is for
representative spilsberry
um I think he's he's got it right like
we've I think we're very close we're
talking about how to do this best and
one question is is there a way to do it
at the wholesale level and I would be
fine with that if we can figure out what
the market value is at the wholesale
level given that some people will be
selling growing manufacturing and
retelling themselves
so my question for you was
you said that there wouldn't be a
problem with interstate commerce whether
we tax at the retail value or the
manufacturing value
um can you walk me through that because
in my brain I'm thinking okay this is
manufactured in South Dakota
South Dakota
taxes their own businesses right so if
you have a manufacturing business in
South Dakota
you're gonna
pay for what you're manufacturing and
get taxed in South Dakota
um if New Hampshire wants to capture
taxes can you walk me through would we
would we be looking
where the how how is it the same for New
Hampshire because I see if we're taxing
15 retail that's clear to me I don't
quite get the manufacturing part of it
sure
I'll try to be clear
I believe that the commissioner is is
using the term wholesale
in the context of the cost to the
retailer
of the final form of the product
and so it doesn't make a difference if
you are trying to ascertain the
wholesale value
whether it was cultivated in South
Dakota or cultivated in New Hampshire in
either case the wholesale value is the
cost to the retailer
who by definition resides or is situated
in New Hampshire so the only thing we're
even trying to tax is a sale that occurs
in New Hampshire
that's why it doesn't make a difference
from the perspective of interstate
commerce whether we tax the value
that the retailer obtains the product at
versus the value that the retailer sells
which is to say to the final consumer
so there they both
satisfy the concern of whether a law is
structured in a way that would
accommodate the the evolution of federal
law in our Direction
is that clear and and I think it's also
very important to say
that I agree completely
with the earlier parts of your comments
um we're talking about a market value
there is nothing in this law that I see
or there's nothing in the commissioner's
comments that imply that the commission
would set the price
that's not what we're talking about
we're talking about monitoring the
market and taxing it accordingly
representative Platt thank you Mr Vice
chair
um we The Liquor Commission has been
very helpful to us today to have us
understand the mechanisms and we've
discovered that it's not at a wholesale
level it's at a distributor level
essentially or want either either or if
they're wholesaler is the distributor
we haven't uh it with the next thing we
want the commission to do is estimate
revenues and we we can't tele ask the
commission to do that till we settle on
the great
and so I would hope we'd come out of
here with a straw poll what rate we
could support
so that the commission can work on it
over the weekend when we come back for
exec we have that information
Let's uh
um the time being 12 10. let's try to
um I'll just take a few more comments in
the next five minutes I want to stop at
12 15 and
um and reconvene at one but um
while while the rate is important
the the thing that we're getting stuck
on is the language of how this should be
how this should be taxed and we will get
to the rate take a few more questions
representative Army
on
first on on this I would like to work
with representative billsbury on the
language I think it's still not
clear enough
market value whether we're talking about
the cost to the retailer which I think
is clear
or otherwise but also I don't want to
discourage people but we
the finance committee doesn't get to
look at this
on there is all a language about the
distribution of whatever money there is
which we all know is a little off uh and
there is also how much it is going to
cause how much The Liquor Commission
needs
and anybody else needs to
to enact to activate this
uh representative spilsbury thank you Mr
chairman yes
um before we break for lunch I just
wanted to signal that I think there is
an entire discussion to be had about the
distribution
of the money and the fund and so we have
some work to do when we come back from
lunch
that's right we actually have
as uh
The Madam chair mentioned there's three
areas we're trying to hit Area one is
what we're working on right now area two
is a distribution and area three is just
cleaning up any uh typos and and uh
inconsistencies
to make it work
right uh representative likely thank you
um
yes I think what can we charge what's
the rate and I think it's just a little
bit less than our neighbors right and it
seems like if this
um is accurate that kind of lays out
what some of our neighbors are doing am
I correct in understanding that that
these
um I understand there's kind of some
breakouts plus sales tax plus whatever
but the initial
numbers the initial percents are on
retail
so I think
so when it says Arizona 22.5 percent
California 23.3 percent plus cultivation
tax up to 1.3 percent by weight that
23.3 percent
it's not consistently on retail uh
representative all me can you answer it
yeah on what I did was I took the sales
and excise taxes
that are clear in here though the
cultivation tax level and is sometimes
unclear on and
if
as in this particular case Colorado has
a 15 excise tax and a 15 retail sales
tax I multiplied
1.15 times
1.15 and then
took away one the excise tax being on
the retail price
yeah the excise tax
is is probably on the marijuana as it
transfers to the manufacturer so what I
would throw out there for us to consider
over lunch
is
um what might that rate be that's just a
little bit less than our neighbors and
between looking online and looking here
I think it's not going to be far from 15
but I certainly would not want to over
tax it so I wonder if we can all kind of
think about that and if we're talking
about not doing it at the retail level
but at the wholesale level that's going
to involve a whole guessing game of
you know if we're if our neighbors are
charging it on the retail so just food
for thought before we break for lunch
yes I would encourage people to think
about this over lunch representative
well I just want to comment I think
that's where the 15 came from
understanding that it was higher up in
the Chain versus on a retail level I
think that's where they in their
discussions and speaking with members of
of Commerce where they came up with that
number because they didn't want
something so low that in taxing
wholesale that it would be lost so they
wanted to have it a little higher so
that is appreciable
and make sure it's getting getting uh I
will do everything copy this and get it
to everybody if we can have 45 minutes
for lunch yes you can have 45 minutes
for lunch uh one is a quick yes I point
out that all the other states had as a
goal driving out illegals none of them
have
and so you have to make it low enough to
do that and you want to be more than
competitive with the pre the other
states around us so we get the business
here and so I would argue for something
a lot less than 15 especially since it's
applied at a distributor level not not a
wholesale not a not a not a Grower's
level
okay we're going to take a 45 minute
break we'll be back here at one o'clock
and I would encourage everyone to think
about uh think about this
foreign
over uh
but
the liquor store next exit signing
Networks
a lot of information
um
they're selling those leather without
voice
I looked at it once now it shows up on
Facebook
in fact
foreign
a little bit
okay we are going to get started back up
again
everyone should have a new handout which
is um basically um
a couple sentences five lines
in an attempt to try to
figure out what we've been discussing
this morning in terms of how the
taxation how and where the taxation
happens and
um
so you all have that before you I'll
give you uh
one minute to read it and then I'm going
to recognize representative spilsbury
actually I'll recognize you now
thank you Mr chairman um
so this represents
an effort to modify a single sentence
that appears in the bill on page 22
lines 27 and 28.
and that's the sentence that
um
describes the 15 tax and the purpose of
this language which I'll walk you
through
is to establish with Clarity what that
15 percent exactly applies to
consistent with our discussion that it
would be the wholesale level I.E the
cost to the retailer
so I do this by drawing from defined
terms that you find back on page three
and four
as you as I read through this I want you
to see that
the term retail cannabis store is a
defined term the term cannabis is a
defined term cannabis products is a
defined term cannabis cultivation
facility is a defined term cannabis
product manufacturing facility is a
defined term so those five defined terms
pull a lot of the specifics that we've
been talking about into this one
sentence
attacks on the monthly total gross
revenue
that was in the bill
now we add derived from sales or
transfers to a retail cannabis store
of either cannabis or cannabis products
that covers the waterfront on products
raw and improved
by either a licensed cannabis
cultivation facility or a cannabis
product manufacturing facility that
covers the Waterfront in terms of
entities that precede the retail level
is imposed at the rate of 15 percent
and this would then allow
the I you may also notice that uh in in
addition to say derived from sales it
says derived from sales or transfers and
this would allow the Liquor Commission
to take account of a vertically
integrated operation and impute a
transfer price
between the manufacturing and the retail
level which is standard in taxation
generally
representative Platt
thank you for the language I love the
language I think it's right on the head
except for the 15 percent
huh
as soon as we get the language agreed to
we'll talk about the percent
representative Almy
yes um
at least paragraphs Roman two and three
to remove the word cultivation
because you have to refer also to the
manufacturing well all right take your
point
um but perhaps the better way to do that
is in both cases
add the term cannabis product
manufacturing facility I think that's
the way to do it okay
thank you for that I hadn't noticed it's
longer
and I'm not sure
in four
whether
they were just concentrating on the
cultivation facilities that also hold a
cannabis product manufacturing facility
license or retail cannabis store license
if we don't need to talk also about the
the tax rates and procedures for license
manufacturing facilities
that also help hold a retail license
did you have a comment on that
representative I think the language
Works uh the way it is but because I
think it's reciprocal
it's basically if you're more than one
thing
um I don't know if you've heard what
representative spilsbury said he said he
believes that this language is
appropriate
well if we have manufacturing facilities
that are not integrated to the farmer we
have manufacturing facilities that are
not integrated to the farmer level but
are integrated to the retail cannabis
store we have the same problem
what
why not just um
do it relative to tax rates and
procedures for licensed cannabis
cultivation facilities and cannabis
product manufacturing facilities
or that hold multiple cannabis licenses
well it's the only ones that are going
to be paying tax or these two yeah right
efficient
representative Ames I had difficulty
hearing you could you just repeat your
suggestion uh my suggestion is that we
insert after licensed cannabis
cultivation facilities
and
licensed cannabis product manufacturing
facilities
yeah period what we're trying to Define
is that they don't get taxed twice no
this is this is not this is the rules so
this is essentially what the Liquor
Commission can write rules to address
right and uh and and that is where
they're involved in more than one of
these activities right
I guess that's right yeah I don't know
where they need it
so we're okay with that
right
I think that has to be
a link
manufacturing facility details oh I
think there has to be a link between the
manufacturing facility and the retail
store if it's being taxed at the
manufacturing level
there there has to be a link between how
about we simplify the sentence
by saying relative to tax rates and
procedures for any entity holding more
than one license
more than this has to do with the
transfer situation of vertical
integration that's a good solution
can you read it as it reads now please
yes so I'm suggesting the commission
shall adopt rules under RSA 541-a
relative to tax rates and procedures for
any entity holding more than one license
under this statute
would they not do that for somebody
holding one license
I I I think your point is well taken I
think that this was drafted to address
the transfer problem that uh
Representatives uh ellsberger and
leapley have you know articulated quite
well but I think it could be broader in
the in the way that you're saying
that's a good question and I I think
that uh it should be broader and so I
what I would suggest is that the
commission shall adopt rules under RSA
541-a
relative to the tax imposed by this
section or something like that or any
licensee for any licency yeah
relative to the tax
right secret seizures you better leave
it to Terry
it is
it
what do you have we so we are shifting
the thrust of the um of this provision
this sentence uh as it was drafted what
it was meant to do is deal with those
entities who have multiple licenses
representative fellows uh
text
text that is good if I would just
suggest taking out the a before the
Cannabis product manufacturing so it
looks like the license belongs to both
of them
I think that's good I don't think we
need rules for
dealing with
multiple licenses because
the the person who grows the cannabis
only has two places that he can sell it
he can either sell it to the
um the people who who are gonna
what do they do they
they do they make the products you know
the intermediate people or the retail so
I think that's fine I don't think you I
don't think you need rules related to
um more than one license but I do think
you need to we need to have some kind of
words related to
transfers in something about how to and
it's how to determine the value of the
Cannabis when it's transferred
and not sold well the value of that
value is going to be in the rule making
of the uh liquid Community that's part
of they're going to be putting those in
rules what the what those values are
well that's what I'm saying that I think
we need to do what what makes you think
it's already in rules
it's not it's not already in rules
that's part of what they have to do is I
think in in your rule making
authorization don't don't we have things
that say
rules about
doesn't isn't there a rule making
section that tells you what you need
rules about
it's usually at the end
well it has there has to be something in
here about making rules somewhere and
usually
there's some kind of scope of the rules
that they can do I don't know where it
is
no creations
well so this was not designed I I didn't
draft this I'm just trying to interpret
it I don't believe this sentence was put
in there as a general authorization of
rule making Authority I think it was an
instruction specifically to have rules
that address those entities that are
vertically integrated or have multiple
licenses so it's um it's on page 31.
starts at line 22
it's it's rule making Authority for the
commission
and it says
so it's adding it to rules that the
commission already has related to liquor
so they have to for cannabis licensing
it says that the things that they have
to do
for application
to issue transfer deny that's like
applications
they collect fees I think it
I think it needs to say more than that I
determination of price
return determination of value
when the products transferred so I think
I think we risk getting very confused
here and I can't even give you a clear
answer to what I think about what you've
just said without going and reading what
RSA 17614 is all about and what uh
inserting a new paragraph nine how it
fits in the context of that law but
just bear in mind that these Provisions
towards the end are each separate
amendments of the law whereas the
provisions we're reading on the bottom
of page 22
are a part of this entire chapter
that's called regulation of cannabis
starting back on page three right so I
think this is a specific rule making
instruction regarding a an issue that is
thorny
and I don't see the point of moving it
so so the
you know I'm I I was on e-dna and I'm
I'm on gel car
so I understand I'm I wouldn't say I'm
an expert but I just I do understand
about rule making and
um you have to in the bill you need to
Grant the agency
you grant the agency authority to make
rules but you have to say rules about
what
so I think that's what this is all about
the licensing part so I think that we
would also need a sentence you know one
of these ABC we need D that would be
like determination of
the value when product is transferred
something I certainly agree with your
predicate that there needs to be rule
making Authority this relates to the
determination of the tax
whereas the other language you were
pointing to on 31 relates to the license
process
which is why you need to add it
license tax
correct they need rule making Authority
for both
that's what this sentence reports to do
where where are you
where are you putting this sentence
on which page
so on the bottom of page 22 okay that's
not
you have to you put this in and then you
give them rule making Authority
you give you give the commission rule
making authority to determine the
valuation
of the product no isn't that what the
words the commission shall adopt rules
under 541a does
31a
for any assistance
okay so that's what he said
representative Olney
thank you
usually you don't see the rule making in
two different places so yeah
and since you don't it's probably a good
idea to put it
put some reference to it in the
rulemaking authority
part two
I think but
I just want to
say The Liquor Commission since they
missed the first part of this but they
have read
read the controlling paragraph now on
we're trying to figure out the easiest
way to change two three and four so that
we're looking at a tax which is levied
on the manufactured level or
the
the producer level that is
not
that is only taxed once
and
you you I presume are the ones that gave
this language to the chair of Commerce
and I'm worried if we go too far away
from your language if it will go too far
away from your procedures and make it
harder too
comply so I just
want to make sure you're in the
conversation
um
representative Ames
so I'm back to trying to sort out what
should be in subsection Roman four
of the
section 318-ft 23. and I think there
should be a first point I think there
should be a section about the rulemaking
for tax for the tax
and this is a good place for it and then
I would go back to what I tried to get
at before and uh and keep it General so
the commission shall adopt rules under
RSA 541a relative tax rates and
procedures
needed to implement the provisions of
this section
yeah
yeah I like it
he's running too
yeah yeah that's gonna be a challenge
but Mike my question on that would be
though where it says relative to tax
rates
aren't we already setting the tax rate
in paragraph one that's a good point to
the tax rate
the tax rate the tax rate okay
don't want to confuse that issue yeah
representative who Among Us is a taken
on scrivening responsibilities
to capture these points that we since we
sense people are agreeing on okay as
long as it's being done
representative spilsbury is uh got
section one my my suggestion is that
the sentence that replaces
um
subsection one
the added into representative to Seth's
Amendment
yeah along with
in
subsections two and three
the addition of the phrase after
cannabis cultivation facility
to insert or cannabis product
manufacturing facility
both places
are you capturing what representative
Ames just said and then in in section
four I was going to ask representative
Ames to read his language once again
um am I on the stage yeah
all right um
what I have is the commission shall
adopt rules under under RSA 541-a
relative to the tax rate
and procedures
for
and procedures needed to implement the
provisions of this section
just to confirm that your sub State your
scribe of the moment
the commission shall adopt rules under
RSA 541a relative to the tax rate and
procedures
needed to implement the provisions of
this section work for you
yes for me
all right it's good to see good to see
progress
um
representative elberger
thank you Mr chair acting chair
um just at the risk of beating a dead
horse yet again I'd like to make sure
that the not on page two or page three
is uh removed all right uh page three
last sentence the facility shall not
page three cannabis cultivation facility
shall not produce cannabis concentrates
if you want to produce them you have to
have a manufacturing license as well
um
we go back to page 22 where it doesn't
say manufacturing it says licensed
cannabis cultivation facility which we
heard includes
manufacturing cultivation preparation
and packaging
on I'm just no we're we're using this
which gives you
gives you a choice on Sorry by either a
licensed cannabis cultivation I forgot
this week was replacing the whole thing
yeah all right I apologize the other
thing is I'm not sure are we discussing
at this point
um who is going to be paying this 15 tax
or are we just discussing sort of more
generalized type language
I can clarify that yeah
so the payur of the tax
is
specifically uh the Cannabis cultivation
facility right or the Cannabis product
manufacturing facility according to the
monthly total gross revenue derived from
sales that were transfers to a retail
cannabis store I I wanted to be clear
that that's what you were saying because
in that case I need to make clear that I
disagree with that decision
okay I would rather see that the final
purchaser of the product
be responsible for the tax
okay any other comments on this area if
not we'll move on to
our next topic
saying no
where how we're going this amendment
unread and undiscovered no no no we
still need to discuss at that time uh
we still need to discuss the amendment
but what we've just talked about the
changes they will be integrated into uh
representative doucet's Amendment we
still need to review that
um
it is can we clarify your Amendment
include where the money goes
okay excuse me before we I understood we
were going to talk about the tax rate
before we moved on to good solution good
point well yeah or we can talk about it
when we go through
representative doucet's Amendment do you
have a preference representative descent
whether we doesn't matter okay we can we
can talk about it to me but are we going
to talk about the rate should we talk
about the distribution and any
possibilities of changing what we have
in front that's a good point what we
have in front of us first yeah maybe we
should talk about this representative
spilsbury catch up with the scribble
here yeah yeah we'll uh go back to
representative spilsbury
um I was very proud to be part of the
discussion of the Ways and Means
Committee last term where we really
thrashed through
the trade-offs and choices about how the
funds would be distributed
and I would like to propose that we draw
straight from HB 1598 last term in
specific uh the allocation of these
funds
I've got the language here in front of
me it's long and tedious to read excuse
me so we're not going to talk about the
rate I got confused I thought we agreed
we were going to talk about that uh we
will get we're going to talk about the
rate but we thought we should talk about
so we're putting this aside
and we're talking about distribution and
then we'll come back to this
right so I know at the point right
exactly because that rate may get
affected by what we talk about now
distribution wise
possibly maybe not but
I think the important thing is we agreed
to wording that I think we were all
struggling with all morning and now the
rate you know
I think a lot of us were bracketing
questions because we wanted to
understand the language and then we were
good because I don't think it's a
foregone conclusion that we all agree
this should be taxed at the manufacturer
rate or that it should be taxed at 15
percent and I think we were all being
patient for this language to get ironed
out so then we could talk about those
two things
um so it seems like our patience is now
being tried it's by moving on to
distribution
with total deference I'm perfectly
willing to
that's fine it's not it's not super
critical for us to jump to something
else right now so let's finish uh let's
finish this topic um so I'll take uh
input on
the rate
I've got a representative Lee since she
mentioned it first
thank you
um
so as we're discussing I just to make
clear it sounds like the question about
transfer
price is being shifted and that we are
assuming that the Liquor Commission will
set a price
so that when
someone owns both
cannabis cultivator
or manufacturer and they're selling to
themselves as a retail store that the
market may not
especially early on may not make clear
what the value of that product is and so
the Liquor Commission is being charged
with
setting a market rate
to make sure that an appropriate tax is
paid
for manufacturer is that what we is that
what this language says
[Music]
well this language doesn't say all that
but the bill in concert with this
language says that the Liquor Commission
right will through rules set what those
rates are and they'll be rates that are
based on the best information they have
for what the market rate should be it
doesn't mean that a retailer won't sell
it for something else but those are the
rates that upon which the tax will be
levied
um
so the other question I have so that
question I established earlier still
have the question but my other question
is about the 15 I think that's uh rate
that people
weren't sure if it was the right rate or
not and that we want to talk about it
when we were talking about loving
attacks on a retail
price I think it was much easier to look
at some of the information that
representative almi shared with us that
lays out what our neighbors
um are taxing their product at and if we
look at Maine Vermont
um Massachusetts
even if we bracket a question that's a
little bit hard for me to to get at for
example in Maine they have a number of
excise taxes
um
is it a flower is it trim is it a plant
even if we leave all of that tax revenue
out and just look at the excise tax tax
and the sales tax they're charging 15
15.5 percent on a retail product right
in Massachusetts they're charging 17
percent
if you put the excise and the state
sales tax together
um and Vermont they have an excise tax
of 14 on the sales tax sales price plus
six percent on the state uh sales tax so
it looks like if we just guessed
and set a retail price at 15 percent we
would be beating everyone in the
neighborhood
but if we're now talking about putting
it on wholesale
I'm not sure if any of the experts here
know
what the markup tends to be like an
average markup between wholesale or
manufacturing and Retail it seems that
now we have to do some translating on
what that
what an appropriate rate would be so I
don't know if we can get any information
if there are any experts here who could
speak to that
I saw a hand go up you want to come up
introduce yourself and answer the
question
my name is Nathaniel Gurion I live in
Sandwich
um
I'm the executive director of the New
Hampshire cannabis party um
who was advocating for common sense
cannabis legalization and I also run a
financial services firm that helps
people and operators and banks with
cannabis banking Financial Services
MasterCard fees and the like
um
you know typically
you know the wholesale price
that a retailer would pay for an ounce
of pot nationally is in the ballpark of
I don't know 75 or so and generally
they're retailing it for in the
neighborhood of
well forty to fifty dollars for an
eighth which comes out to three or four
hundred dollars so there is a very
significant uh you know it's not
necessarily just a fifty percent or a
hundred percent markup uh so if you're
taxing
um at a cultivator wholesale level
at fifteen percent that might be
equivalent to a retail tax rate of four
or five percent
um it may be easier
to
just set this at a I mean I know it kind
of undoes some of what you guys were
talking about but it might be easier to
just set this
um set a tax rate on the retail level uh
that would cover everything that was
sold at a clear and definable value you
know one of the I think one of the
perspectives that I it would be helpful
to share
um is
that you guys are kind of getting a
little sample especially this morning
about how complex this would get
um and it's it's probably going to be
very difficult to come up with a formula
that's perfectly good
um you know I would um argue in favor of
simple
um and flexible
especially since um
you know otherwise the regulatory burden
is going to get pretty substantial
and also this is an industry that's not
mature it's in flux it's very
complicated
um and you know interstate commerce is
undoubtedly coming sooner or later
whether we embrace it or it is put upon
us
um and federal legalization is going to
happen at some point whether it's a
system Mr chair
we were asking for some input on setting
the market rate of cannabis I appreciate
the testimony but we're not here to hear
uh testimony I'm sorry point taken so
thank you thank you
does a Liquor Commission want to say
anything regarding this
the retail retail versus wholesale
pricing taxing
I just want to make sure I understand
the question I
I I think the question can you ask it
again yes you can ask
um the question was
our neighbors are taxing a product at
retail
um we're talking about taxing the
product at wholesale or manufacture
so how could we compare those two rates
it might help if we knew kind of what
the markup was from uh manufacturer to
retail
and sounds like the testimony we heard
before
might be like three or four times
that's that's what we have understood to
be kind of the market rate
and and again I think that the goal is
obviously to sell more product than they
do in the states across from us and
Massachusetts given given what
Massachusetts has done that's bolstering
the main business I mean you can see
that growth in Maine has been
what I would consider astronomical for
the time that they've been in business
so
I think our goal of of taxing it
uh at the finished product rate will
keep that low whatever rate you decide I
feel that 15 is is very amenable but if
you decide it should be less I still
think with the amount of business that's
going to bleed over from Maine
Massachusetts and Vermont we will have a
substantial business in a very short
period of time
I'd like to go to representative Doucet
you've proposed in your Amendment eight
percent you want to talk to that sure
thank you Mr chairman and some of my
commentary
goes right to what the commission was
talking about we heard testimony as to
why this rate was set at 15 I don't know
if anybody heard anything different than
I did but it sounded Mighty arbitrary
Mighty arbitrary we've heard testimony
about how other States neighboring or
not have done it wrong done it wrong we
do things correctly in New Hampshire we
talked about I know we did last biennium
excuse me last biennium about
undercutting most importantly the black
market make no mistake we are we all
heard testimony we all know this to be
fact that people are getting their
cannabis whether it's legally in Maine
Massachusetts Vermont now or if they're
buying it on a street corner
what we need to do is set the bar as a
state let's not count on so many
millions of dollars of Revenue going out
to shoot let's count on
a b being the best at what it is that
we're looking down the barrel of I don't
necessarily support or not support
cannabis as a product or its use or
anything I'm a supporter of Revenue
whether that's minuscule from the start
and it's going to take a long time for
this to get off the ground but let's be
the leaders nationally in this this
eight percent is very specific it
undercuts everybody it makes us the
benchmark
eight percent puts us in a position
where we can undercut most importantly
to me because I've suffered personal
issues
undercuts what we're hearing from our
constituency perpetually the the
poisoning of and and the
the black market you know stuff with
fentanyl I I would much rather
have my 30 year old Sons buy a product
if they choose to do so at Joyce's
cannabis Palace in Berlin
knowing that that product is good it's
tested it's fair in price very fair in
taxes the fairest in the country in
taxes because we do it right in this
state
instead of going to the alley behind
Joyce's cannabis Palace
in Berlin and picking up a bag of pot
who knows where the supplier is and
we've all heard the horror stories so
let's get it right and we're working
cooperatively here and we're looking
down the barrel of that this is
something that's a reality and we we
should be the leaders in this we should
be the tip of the spear
in setting The Benchmark low so we get
the business from the other states much
much like liquor
okay and and somebody can correct me if
they heard a reasoning as to why it was
set at 15 but I've done the comparisons
and we've seen a lot of uh
pieces passed out today I assure you
eight percent is the lowest in the
country
tax-free New Hampshire remains tax-free
New Hampshire even within eight percent
tax excise tax or whatever label you
want to put on it it's revenue for the
state and we're still doing it the best
thank you representative Platt I would
compare the eight percent proposed tax
to uh rooms and meals which is what
eight and a quarter now eight uh some
eight and a half uh and so it's not 15.
it's that uh it's rooms and meals and we
don't have a sales tax but if we did I
doubt we'd have anything any higher than
eight percent so compared to a
theoretical sales tax I think it's the
right level
did you want to say something I just
want to clarify something we keep
talking about rooms and meals the fact
all that does is brought rooms and meals
our rooms and meals let's keep it there
we don't have a sales tax let's keep it
there I think you know no matter what
your perspective no matter what side of
your the aisle you're on we understand
it needs to be taxed we understand that
the majority leader said yesterday that
it's a tax let's tax it at the
appropriate point at the appropriate
price and get the appropriate revenue
and build out from there I I don't I
don't think we need to be talking about
retail taxes sales taxes coupling it and
and diluting what is a true meals and
rooms tax and we just get it done
yeah yeah I wasn't directly comparing
confusing what I was doing is that it's
in the range of those other taxes that's
all not higher
all right uh
representative Olney and then
representatively
absolutely no idea how much this is
going to raise
um but I am pretty sure that at eight
and a half percent of what we're talking
about given the large amount of cost it
will bring to the state to The Liquor
Commission budget in particular on that
we will be getting practically nothing
if any anything uh
in to the treasury
out of that on rooms and meals has two
inspectors for meals I think it is
across the entire state
uh and
on
some of the towns including mine went
out and got their own person
and found rats in the kitchens uh that
was in Hanover actually that one
on and
um
and then we've got the tax collection by
dra which is extremely efficient
and that's about all and we we give them
six million a year I think it is for for
um advertising now which helps
grow that a lot
this one you you need you said you need
10 new inspectors you need a lot of
other things we haven't looked at yet
um and you need to pay a
adequate Testing Lab
on which is I imagine going to be fairly
expensive
or set up one in the state system and
find a way to pay them enough so that
they'll do a good job so that we don't
end up with fentanyl in the marijuana
and
um it's a totally different proposition
I don't think that it's a proposition
that is going to get us any money so we
wouldn't really need to talk about
distribution thank you
representatively thank you
um I just had a question on the
representatives Amendment
so it talks about eight percent on
cultivation facilities so are we just to
clarify are we pausing the conversation
on this language to talk about the
amendment and then we're going to
compare no the the language that we
talked about will be included submerged
with you so what you're proposing is
this language but you're just talking
about replacing this 15 with an eight
percent okay thank you I wanted to make
sure I understood what we were
discussing thanks
anybody else
representative spilsbury
and I don't feel strongly enough to
resist where a consensus moves so I'm
still waiting to see where that
consensus moves
but given that we have clarified we're
going to move with the wholesale rather
than retail level I'm very comfortable
with 15 at the wholesale level
and if we had landed on the retail then
I would be expecting a sharply lower
figure
representative yes thank you um
representative Doucet brings up some
good points about uh
legitimizing uh an industry and making
sure the industry that we're opening up
is is the best that it can be so I know
we've all been inundated with all kinds
of emails and literatures uh talking
about the um the woes of a legalized
marijuana industry and you know we've
some of those emails that we're getting
are look how bad Colorado is look at how
bad California is so over the past
weekend I think we've all probably done
a little more deeper dive on the tax
rate and if you look at the tax rate of
those states that are telling us how bad
things are they're very expensive I mean
Washington I think close to over 40
percent tax rate on that so I I Echo
Representatives doucets sentiments
in that
you know we do want to get rid of a
black market we do want to make sure
what we're doing here is safe and and
quite frankly we want to make sure that
we are the best and most competitive
state in New England is eight percent
that that number uh I don't know if
that's the number but I think 15 you
know that's a hard gulp for me was from
from the get-go uh so I think there is
some and then going back to what
representative Army was saying about the
inspectors we will need inspectors we
need qualified inspectors we will need a
number of inspectors we don't need all
these I don't believe we would need all
the inspectors at capacity day one as
these things will will ramp up over time
I know
um
you know in in the state of New
Hampshire we have 200 pharmacies that
get inspected every year for uh
everything from contamination to sterile
and non-sterile compounding to
Administration uh of of dangerous drugs
fentanyl legal Administration fennel so
you know I think that as an emerging
industry we don't need to there's a ramp
up uh period with that so that being
said I I would be comfortable going at a
lower end
um you know 15 seems high to me uh
uh you know maybe eight percent is the
number
thank you
commissioner did you have
something or
just wondering if you can I just
wondered if we were through Mr chairman
um yeah I'm happy to continue to answer
any questions thank you okay we may
still have some certainly
representative Albany could we suspend
the rate discussion until we know how
much they're going to need to operate
we won't know how much they're going to
get out of it but at least we'll have
some idea of how much they need to
operate
I mean on the face of it that makes
sense I think the the issue is that this
is going to take two or three years to
get started we're probably going to be
in a deficit for a while to
representative doucet's point we want to
be
we want to be the best states where this
where this is sold and we want to make
sure we're undercutting the black market
because every single one of those States
that's having problems Colorado
California
um on Down the Line their black market
is alive and well and strong and we want
to make sure that's not the case here
because we want this to uh
to be to be again the best state where
this is handled representative elberger
thank you
um representative spilsberry said that
we seem to have come to consensus about
where the tax is going to be
positioned I'd just like to clarify find
out
how much consensus we're at because I
know I disagree with that I don't know
if I'm the outlier here I'd just like to
get an idea
um I think we we had um I don't know if
we have 100 consensus I think we did
have some
um we can take a quick straw poll to see
um how many people agree with the
language that we've come up with so far
um
all those
accepting the tax rate
the language that was handed out the
four lines
that representative spilsbury put
together
with sheet here four lines five lines
accepting for the percentage because
we're still talking about the percentage
how many people agree with this new
language that we have just raise your
hand
one two three
six seven eight nine
okay and how many are disagree
okay
four one two three four so nine nine
agree with it four disagree with it
uh given the
the complex the complication of this
this bill and what we've gone through so
far I think uh nine being four and nine
being for this and four being against I
think we should continue
um our discussions so right now those
discussions are based on the rate
representative elberger yeah
um I I am
we want to be as uh representative
put it uh the best
uh
the best can cover a range
and I am inclined to go more toward the
15 rate uh in part because one of the
things that we also need to be looking
at is
this is a drug
I'm
just put on record I am in support of
legalization but there are going to be
some health problems that come about as
a result and we need to have some money
set aside for things like that and that
should be considered when we look at the
tax rate
representative Ellery and then leapley
thank you for bringing up the health
issues but I believe they already exist
and we're already dealing with them I
don't think this will extend the uh
adverse health effects just because it
becomes legal in New Hampshire when you
can drive two minutes south of the
Pheasant Lane Mall and get anything you
want
uh representative you said just quickly
to that point we're going to get to it
but we have we have a change that
addresses that very issue that
representative spilsberry is gonna
propose
representative liebly thank you
um
I think the taxation on the
retail price is way cleaner way more
simple
um I think most of us around this table
support the free market and that would
uh transparently allow prices to be set
instead of having a government agency
guess at what a price is my other
concern is that when we
move from discussing a retail rate which
makes it so we can compare more easily
with our neighbors to a wholesale rate
um we're skipping a lot of math
so if we want to compare our rate to our
neighbors which I think is an important
consideration when setting a tax rate
um
in fact I don't think I've heard
that any of these numbers are based on
anything
else I'd love to base a tax rate on
something so if if people want to bring
forward what we should base it on it'd
be great but just starting with our
neighbors
So based on the testimony we heard here
based on doing the math it seems like if
we're not charging at the retail level
if we're going to tax at the wholesale
or manufacturing level we have to take
that into consideration and it seems to
me that 15 percent is
way off in that case and in order to
make it comparable with our neighbors we
would have to raise that taxation rate
from 15 percent times it by three or
four
which would make it 45 or 60 tax on the
wholesale or the manufacturing level in
order to be comparable with a 15 tax on
the retail side in Vermont or Maine or
Massachusetts
so I think we haven't even paused
to recognize that if we're moving the
tax from retail to wholesale
that
it's orders of magnitude different so
we'll have to consider when we discuss
the taxation rate we should considering
that consider that we're not taxing at
that rate and so if it was set at 45 to
60 percent at the wholesale rate that
would be comparable to our neighbors 15
on retail so to go from 15 to 8
um worries me because we do have to pay
to regulate
um this new emerging industry and as um
sounds like our colleagues are going to
present on distribution but if we're
going to tax the wholesale at eight
percent my fear is that we won't even be
able to cover the cost of regulating
this industry so I think we need to
pause and and consider what what are we
basing those numbers on and have a
discussion
foreign
why don't we move
on to well
do we want to throw out what the rate
should be or do we want to talk about
distribution
just to suggest you Mr chair maybe maybe
representative spilsberg can offer that
that change
and uh members that served last year
will understand and we can bring
everybody else up to speed that sounds
good let's let's talk about that we'll
come back to the to the race I'd like to
say some more about
um what
representative lippley just commented on
that when you look at Massachusetts
their tax for just the Cannabis not
their regular sales tax is 10.75 percent
and that's at the retail level and what
we heard is to be to make a
comp that would be comparable to a
wholesale tax on just the Cannabis of
maybe three percent
so in 2021
Massachusetts their revenue from
Cannabis was 46 million
so we're talking about what would be
comparable for that given the population
difference
is we're talking about like 10 million
dollars and a significant portion of
that is going to have to go to the
monitoring of the operation I mean
essentially we just
I mean we're not going to make any money
on that and this is Ways and Means and
one of our responsibilities is to look
at revenue and how how we can have
reasonable Revenue in the state we
certainly look at Mr chair at gambling
and Lottery and we say that's that's a
good source of Revenue
because it's discretionary for the
people
who use it nobody is required and nobody
absolutely needs that product and we
should be doing the same thing with this
Revenue
thank you and no disrespect I I think we
need to progress forward we took a straw
poll it was fairly substantial we a
majority of the committee wants to move
forward we've figured out where we want
to tax it
um I'll spend less time comparing New
Hampshire's successes to Massachusetts
and move on please yeah I mean to be
fair we agreed on the wording we did yet
agree on a tax rate but
um let's I I'm sorry we did a straw poll
but I believe that we did a straw poll
assuming that 15 percent meant 15
percent in both places rather than
Representatives leapley's uh analysis
just now and thank you that it actually
is not the same that if we were trying
to get compare 15 on a retail level then
we would need to be charging on the
wholesale level 45 to 60 percent which I
think might be a much harder or pill to
swallow yeah no I think it's clear I
think we understand what you're what
you're saying
um it comes down to what should the rate
be
um
let's um
yes representative
thank you uh I appreciate everything
that's been said and I just want to make
an observation that we did take a straw
poll of those people in the room we did
not take a strong poll of everybody on
the committee
that's all
right representative Doucet
did you
I'm just wondering the purpose of the
straw poll let's let's not do that I'm
not against discussing it but if we're
going to use it let's use it for its
purpose the purpose of the straw poll
was to agree on the wording which the
majority of the people in the room
agreed with
but I did say before the straw poll that
the 15 percent the tax part we would
still try to come upon a final number
representative spillsberg thank you Mr
chairman yes I understood the straw poll
the same way so I think that we will
Circle back to the rate
and maybe it's worth having this next
conversation before we try to come down
I think let's proceed
so picking up where I left off
this committee spent an enormous amount
of effort just last year
um
evaluating the pros and cons of choices
in allocating the funds
and we put the emphasis on education
and I'd like us to restore that emphasis
the
mechanism
in HP 1598 last year
was that after the costs of the
commission have been paid
50 percent of the remaining funds would
be dispersed to the Department of
Revenue Administration to be dispersed
to cities and towns to offset the
education tax imposed on all persons and
property taxable pursuant to RSA 763 and
76-8 that's the swept tax
so half of the net revenue to the state
would go directly
to reducing the burden of the real
estate tax in our municipalities
and I think that's the least it should
be
1598 went on to then allocate the next
30 percent
to offset the Retirement System's
unfunded accrued liability
and it had then a provision which we see
repeated in this year's law
but in the inverse
it says upon certification by the
commissioner of the Department of
administrative services that the
retirement system has no remaining
unfunded accrued liability
this disbursement of funds shall be
credited to the education trust fund
so theoretically
if the Retirement Systems unfunded crude
liability was satisfied we could end up
with 80 percent going to education but
we know from comments and testimony
we've already heard that the likelihood
of that in for coming years is very slim
so effectively it remains 50 percent to
education to offset swept
fifty percent to retirement
to offset the unfunded accrued liability
30 I'm sorry thank you glad to hear
you're listening closely
that leaves
um 20 percent
and 1598 divided that as follows ten
percent of the remaining funds
or 25 million whichever is less shall be
credited to the Department of Health and
Human Services Bureau of drug and
alcohol services for use in
evidence-based voluntary programs for
substance use related education
prevention treatment and recovery so we
were very mindful of the implications of
of having cannabis more freely used
five percent of the remaining funds
shall be distributed dispersed to Public
Safety agencies goes on to specify
police fire rescue
etc etc
and the final five percent again to the
DHHS for children's Behavioral Health
Services
I like that balance it could be tweaked
but I would like to propose that we take
it in its entirety we can then have a
discussion about whether it should be
tweaked the fundamental point of this is
that it shifts the emphasis back to
education
and off of of the retirement liabilities
I'd just like to make a final comment on
that before I give up the floor
um
former representative abrami modeled
some numbers that suggested it would
take 130 years
using this particular source of excess
Revenue
um to satisfy the retirement funds so
it's it's not a solution to that problem
it's a very material contribution to the
extent that it could offset the 363
million dollar swept obligation by
something in the order of 50 to 80
million maybe not in the first year
maybe not in the second but in the third
third fourth years and on and so that's
I'm trying to put the emphasis behind
that mission which is much more tangible
to my constituents
thank you
comments on that
representative leapley
thank you first I just wanted to clarify
did you say was it 10 for health the
Health and Human Services
not the kids one the first one
yes so there are two different
allocations that would be managed by
Department of Health and Human Services
and the 10 was for use in evidence-based
voluntary programs for substance use
related education prevention treatment
and Recovery
and the five percent would be for
children's Behavioral Health Services
thank you for that clarification
um
I remember talking about the 130 years
before
it gets paid off was that according to
the fiscal note
attached
because I feel like could we
get a reminder of
what we're talking about as far as
Revenue
or do we do let's let's not get hung up
on 130 degrees
figuratively that give or take 50 years
it's a long way off right but but to be
clear that was representative of
brahmi's former representative of
brahmes
estimate based on the notion of attacks
in the ballpark of 50 to 57 dollars per
ounce so it took a very very different
path than the one we've embraced okay
so just one final question just trying
to get a handle on some number somewhere
um I think
representative Ami may have referenced
this before we have no idea what it will
cost to administer to oversee this
industry or do we have some idea
thank you
for him to talk about
commissioner you want to address that
certainly thank you Mr chairman well
we've done some Tina has done some
preliminary costs and what is actually
in the fiscal note uh tends to be a
little
a little light
on what
on what really needs to be put in we do
we do have some estimates here that I'll
have
I'll have Tina go through uh one of the
biggest one of the biggest pieces is we
want to make sure when we do this
that
The Liquor Commission funds and the
Cannabis commission funds aren't
co-mingled at any point so we're we're
having to uh set up a separate system we
never want to put the Liquor Commission
Revenue at risk at any time so there has
to be a separate system put into place
to get that done so we'll have Tina go
through them
good afternoon uh so in the first year
uh based on the timing there will be no
salaries and benefits
we've accounted for a stipend that is uh
in the bill for uh current Personnel
that are going to overtake or oversee
this responsibility that's about a
hundred and eighty seven thousand we're
estimating about 250 000 for a
consultant in the first year
uh we we're going to need to look into
renting office space doing some
construction in our building for staff
there's equipment for the positions
office furniture cars and the overhead
expense so in the initial in the first
year
oh and then the Standalone system so
we're going to need to do a standalone
system that is going to do the seed to
sale tracking
and then there's also going to need to
be a system for the licensing and the
auditing aspect and then a financial
system if we're not going to have this
touch the Liquor Commission system we're
going to need a financial system that
this all feeds into and with all of
those costs not including Personnel in
the first year we're estimating about
seven million dollars for the first year
yes my Standalone system you mean a
software data management system correct
purpose that would correct separate from
the Liquor Commission correct
we do if someone could make copies Mr
chairman we do have we do have a draft
we do have a draft
I don't know if we have something
right now thank you Jennifer thank you
thank you very much
thank you
so so that was the first year to have
figures beyond that we have three years
in this okay this
so in in the second year if we were to
become fully staffed
um we would continue with the stipend
which is allocated in the bill for 18
months uh continuing with the consultant
uh the renting of space and the overhead
costs and not knowing how much the new
system is going to cost us so in the
first year we put five million dollars
in for the systems for the licensing and
the seed to sale tracking and the
financial software we also put another
five million in the second year not
knowing how much all of these systems
and Integrations are going to cost us so
in the second year we were estimating
about 8 million
and then once we have all of the systems
in place in the third year for just
maintaining the overhead of the
operations we were estimating about 4.2
million
well so that so maintaining the is 4.2
million what is the
PL that's 4.2 million plus what that's
it that's in year three four okay so
that includes salaries and everything
okay that's everything fully staff
representative fellows so how many
um what kind of assumption did you make
on the number of facilities that you'd
have to interact with
well I think the software is is would be
unlimited so the the
software is I'm asking about the year
three when we'd be operational or at
this point at the end of year three will
there be any facilities open and you'll
be
you know doing oh absolutely I I think
so how many facilities did you assume
this is a cost estimate of what it would
cost The Liquor Commission to do it the
the facilities are privately owned
aren't you going to inspect the
facilities yes how many people seven
people seven seven Enforcement Officers
seven people is how many you'd need to
um inspect in audit or whatever how many
retail outlets and retail outlets and
um
producers and manufacturers
so it
at the point of how the operation runs
behind the scenes the we've estimated
this cost and we have a breakdown on uh
on the org chart in positions that's
something separate that we can we can
hand out to you but it's a the number of
facilities wouldn't be a concern from a
cost standpoint of the Liquor Commission
other than the inspection pieces
the cost of those facilities being open
are borne by the people who open them
I I'm asking about your budget
to for the Cannabis commission operation
you're going to have people
who will have jobs related to this in
inspecting
what whatever I you know processing the
applications managing the money
how many facilities
are you trying to did you put in your
estimate
we didn't do the estimate based on the
number of facilities we did the estimate
based on the final overall need as far
as the number of positions
for running the operations so in the
first year it would be if we were fully
staffed but I don't know if you have a
better answer as far as the number of
facilities you were estimating sorry
thank you for your question
representative Mark armagedian chief of
enforcement for the Liquor Commission
um so that's a unknown number right
because we don't know how many are
coming in but we have to prepare for
what the possibility of what we've seen
in our universe being New England being
that number we're preparing for a
thousand between zero and a thousand
which gives us somewhere and that's
cultivators all the way on through so
what we're looking at is our
investigators are in the ballpark of uh
overseeing somewhere around 200 100 to
200 facilities a piece
um that is auditing and that is doing
compliance and inspections
so multifaceted
and you can see here in the startup cost
that it's including 20 20 individuals to
work for the Liquor Commission
equipment for 20 people laptop printers
phones
Etc
it'll be a complete separate division
the way it's set up so the folks that
are working on the Cannabis piece will
never be touching anything that has to
do with the Liquor Commission piece it's
a separate arm it's a separate division
you have a question representative
representative Almy and then
representative
enforcement
fish officer 's and then 13 that do the
licensing that do the the
um
data data analysis and and
all of that is that the finance yes
absolutely yeah okay and where is the
testing laboratory The Testing
Laboratories are separate facilities
they're businesses that are privately
owned and privately licensed and I
believe in Maine there's three maybe
three in Maine I think there's three in
Maine that do it now and who who would
be paying them
visit the state no they're they're being
paid by the company that's either
manufacturing or growing the products
brings their product to that facility to
be tested and they pay those facilities
to have their products tested
so
the seventh
Heaven going to be going
to do well to do enforcement on who who
is looking at the
um growing facilities that would be the
enforcement investigation that would be
the enforcement of investigators
thank you
and any testing that gets done will be
that the the owner of the growing
facility or the manufacturing facility
picks his own sample and takes it there
that's correct they go to those Sam
everything that they grow and or
manufacture before it can be sold has to
be tested everything everything it has
to go through that process
and it has to go to those again the
reason the reason I believe it's been
done this way is because it's it's near
the twain shall meet the manufacturers
and Industry uh people that are growing
are are not involved and cannot be
involved with the testing facilities
it's a separate business it's a separate
license
so the
the grower that has
500 pounds or 200 pounds of marijuana
leaf will take all of it to the testing
facility and they'll do the sampling
they they will do the they will take it
by the skew is is is my understanding of
it when it when a seed is planted it has
a skew so when that when that product is
gone
ask your stock keeping unit which is
it's just your but your barcode
everything gets a barcode every plant
gets a barcode so when that plant goes
to be sold that plant is taken to the
testing facility and tested now in the
facilities that I've seen especially the
indoor facilities most of them are you
know 20 25 30 000 square feet so you
have a facility that's then divided into
let's say five or six thousand square
foot squares and each one of those rooms
is a grow room so there's heating
lighting air conditioning air
conditioning humidity and there's some
where between
300 and to 600 plants in that room
so they're all given a skew they're all
given uh they're they're all grown and
every one of those facilities each one
of those individual facilities within
that larger facility most of them have a
a reproductive rate of every two weeks
they're harvesting a room so there's a
lot of product that's rolling through
these rooms and you know from being
planted to seed to through a product
until it's harvested so uh
these testing facilities are are pretty
vast they have to be able to take in a
lot of product and testing and obviously
there'd be several of those we think as
well as a smaller manufacturers
okay
um
as time goes on we're losing more and
more people so um I'm gonna go to
representative roachford and then I want
to focus back on representative
spilsbury's presentation of the
allocation and kind of get that under
our belt because as you can see there's
a lot there's a lot to discuss here but
we need to contain it and continue to
make progress so representative great
thank you and I just wanna
you set a number here I want to make
sure I I got it right uh so there's
seven maybe seven on seven Enforcement
Officers I got that and I think you said
each officer you're anticipating
will be will be responsible for 200
separate licensees
I believe that the chief uh sent up two
up to 200. okay all right so some of
these facilities are obviously small
facilities sure absolutely
um so you're anticipating a pretty
pretty uh widespread adoption and you
know you're anticipating some pretty
growth in this industry absolutely this
this has the ability to be a very robust
business so I think that maybe it sounds
like maybe I mean you've been hearing
some of our you know
hesitations or questions about
um
is it going to be viable is there going
to be enough Revenue it doesn't sound
like you're you and you've done a lot of
research you've told you've testified of
that all day it doesn't sound like
you're worried about Revenue with this
no why I I will only say they're the one
caveat is the the time that it takes the
investors to build their facilities and
grow the product so there's there's from
my understanding of it usually the first
growth is is a throwaway growth they
they grow it they test it and then as
they start to grow they kind of they
stockpile it so they they cultivate the
bud they start to manufacture so there's
a period of time from one to three years
where there'll be uh very little Revenue
other than the licensing revenue and
then as
again one of the one of the cautionary
tales that I've been told is make sure
you have your cultivation and
Manufacturing in place with plenty of
stock to sell because when you do open
those
80 90 100 stores in the state they're
going to you have to fill the pipeline
first and then there'll be the revenue
uh the constant Revenue that comes in
and you know even with as many
facilities as they have in Maine
my understanding has been that they uh
they are on at the limit of what the
manufacturers can currently grow so uh
so I guess to answer your question
representative we're not concerned about
uh
the the revenue once everything is
brought up to speed it's not if it will
happen it's it's kind of when it will
happen and we we feel that there's a lot
of people in the state that are willing
to invest uh given that the state is
going to be in control of it and given
our history as the Liquor Commission
thank you
okay so um let's get back to what
representative spilsbury uh presented in
terms of where the money would go
thoughts
on that
I'd like it a lot better
I like it a lot better
thank you representative roachford I
concur with that I think representative
spilsbury brought up the fact about our
constituents are asking for help in
education and and this would do that so
I I would concur
um representative Doucet and I'm in
agreement too I think we we drilled down
if you remember correctly with the
breakdown with that piece of legislation
last year and specific to HHS naming
specific uh purposes to use those funds
and this makes a heck of a lot more
sense
representative Platt and then
representative fellows not only do I
agree I think it's beyond our purview to
change that's policy that's already been
baked in we're after the rate we're at
level
did you want to comment I'd like to just
respond directly to that
um
this is essentially a dedicated funds
dedicated funds are fundamentally a ways
and means issue
representative fellows thank you
um
having been on Edna and also have having
had a conversation with Marty Kalin who
works for retirement
um and I can tell you from this report
from the retirement system that the
unfunded actual Actuarial liability as
of June
30th
2022 was 5.7
billion that's billion with a B
and there is already in existence
existence it might even be in statute
I'm not sure uh a schedule for paying
down that unfunded liability and it's
paid for by the employers
and it's scheduled to be paid off
in 2039
if we're looking at
30 percent of the revenue from cannabis
and sending that to address the unfunded
liability it wouldn't
um remove it wouldn't change what the
employers have to contribute what it
would do is make it end a little bit
earlier so instead of 2039 it might end
in 2038 but given the magnitude of what
we're talking about here you know
getting rid of
um
you know five billion dollars worth of
debt the amount of money we could put in
would have a very minimal effect on
getting rid of that unfunded liability
it wouldn't be it I don't even think it
would make it one year earlier it would
just
be a minor contribution for that reason
I would like to suggest that we take out
the unfunded liability altogether and
move that into the education funding
but the concept you know to have it go
to education I totally support
yes representative
thank you
um I also just am trying to make sure I
get this that the 50 would be an offset
to swept
so
um the property tax bills would lower by
however that much turned out but the
overall uh impact in terms of funding
for Education would not be changed by
this this would simply be a change in
source
that's an extremely important point I
agree with you
it does not direct more money to
education
it's simply
changes and shifts the burden somewhat
off of a real estate property tax
every time I have a conversation with
any other legislator about how we could
embark on phasing out and getting rid of
the swept tax I always get hit with find
me an alternative source
and I just follow up on that because
it's
because it's education funding so
um I think that we could put in here and
if if we have more money than it than it
takes to get rid of swept which is
363 million dollars a year so I sort of
doubt we'll ever get to that level then
you could say put it in the trust fund
or put it in one of the other things I
mean 363 million is a lot of money
representative Bolton
and then representative Doucet having
heard the estimates of uh actually how
much revenue we could possibly get from
this and the fact that it was a state
employee working for Health Human
Services for 20 years I've also been
um a um yeah select person for the town
of Plymouth I'm thoroughly in favor of
the breakdown of these funds
thank you representative and and that's
what I to to Echo what representative
Boyd just said the towns incur the costs
for their employees for the for a
component or a percentage of the
retirement system so either way we're
impacting you know the taxpayers we know
that they the unfunded mandates of a
mountain high to climb maybe we could
differentiate the you know uh Flip Flip
the percentage and maybe give 50 to the
swept and 30 to is that where it's at no
it's already there so but I think
there's I think it's that is a
substantial issue and we heard testimony
relative to that last biennium and I
think that this breakdown is is a fair
breakdown we're not going to overcome
that that unfunded obstacle that we all
have in front of us but it gives at
least uh the towns that
a view towards you know a break on that
in the swept will will be easy live
get over
thank you thank you
representative blue please
hold hold that thought I saw
a hand from quinoa
did you wanna
good afternoon King Ming Wong text
policy Council from the dra
um the department does not have a
position on the bill and since we're
talking about the distribution of the
funds to the calculation of the searches
feel like this is the opportune time for
me to bring this up for for the
discussion uh with the committee uh it
is the in terms of the timing of when
the money would be deposited into the
ETF for the calculation of the um this
is the rate for the swept taxes and this
language is uh in both the current
amended HP 639 as well as in the uh
prior years HB um 12.
1598 1598 that's right
um and it says at the end of the uh the
sentence at the end of the paragraph
that says that the bill the the rate
shall be applied to the uh the effective
next fiscal year
um essentially right now if we're
talking about next fiscal year is fiscal
year 24
the swap rate has already been
calculated for fiscal year 24.
um so it's just a matter of
clarification in terms of when that
rates be will be applicable so it would
be whether
would this be undoing the rate that has
already been calculated for fiscal year
24 versus would this be a rate that
would be applicable for the cat in the
consideration for the calculation in
fiscal 25 rates so that's just something
that probably
maybe certain um cleaning up of the
language or if it's really evident there
then then there's no need to to clarify
that just to bring this up for the
committee's consideration okay
thank you I I don't know the answer to
that but
uh does anybody know when that would
apply
well I
I concur with uh I mean it makes sense
with King Wong the language in our bill
specifically says this rate shall be
effective for the following fiscal year
okay so it's it's based on what occurs
in this year affecting the rate to be
determined for swept next year
so if that's how the language is uh is
being read then uh probably it needs to
be um clarified what's the intention of
the uh the legislation whether is it to
have it effective if um the next fiscal
year or have it be effective for the
calculation for the next calculation for
the swept rate which will be the
following that we should be in the
fiscal year following the next fiscal
year essentially
representative fellows so I I don't know
which page you look
you look on me so I'm what I'm wondering
is I think you're talking about
um applying it
before you print the warrant
exactly but so I'm wondering is there
any possibility that you
send the warrant out just the way we're
doing it now
but when it comes time to set the tax
rate
you use the money that's identified at
that point almost make it look like a
revenue
do you understand what I'm saying well
when the warn is sent out the uh
the rate that
the amount that needs to be collected by
the town has been determined
right so um so that would be when uh and
then
and then further on late later on uh the
rate will be determined
at a later date
um in the collection of um of that for
that particular amount in that
particular town
um so I believe that this since the war
has already been sent out the amount
it's already been calculated what amount
has needs to be collected for by each
municipality to get to the 363 million
um and I believe this
the language in this bill is to reduce
that warrant warrant amount yeah
so I I still don't know where the
language is but I'm just you know
hearing what you're saying I'm wondering
can
somehow change the language so what you
would do is when
I don't know some somehow we apply it
when we're setting the tax rates
excuse me I think representative
spilsbury has found something if you
look at page 22
hb639
the first the first section B that you
see in lines one through eight
includes second sentence starting at the
end of line four
for the purpose of setting the education
tax rate under RSA 76 3 the amount of
Revenue required to be collected
pursuant to RSA 76 3 shall be reduced by
the amount transferred to the education
trust fund is required in this
subparagraph and the commission shall
set the rate at a level sufficient to
generate the reduced amount
and that rate
shall be effective for the following
year
so it means once this program is up and
running
revenues are generated they're
distributed according to this allocation
the commissioner will
take the allocation
763 tells them to raise 363 million and
distributed amongst the town
76 8 I think it is tells them how to go
about setting the rate for the next year
so so there's two tax rates at play here
so there's at one point which is
I think it must be at least a year
before the beginning of the fiscal year
there is a tax rate is set
to to print the warrant and the warrants
goes to the towns and says this is how
much money you're going to have to raise
from taxes for swep
T and it also is part of the education
funding formula because the funding
formula says this is figures out how
much they're entitled to in the town
subtracts the swep and the balance is
what they get as a grant
when it comes time to actually send out
the tax bills that's like a whole year
later and it actually gets they take the
warrant amount and then they apply it to
the
um
they apply they they know how much the
town knows how much it has to raise in
it appla applies to the local valuation
so there are two points that you can
intercept I'm not totally sure I'm
following you but let me let me give you
my best shot
when you say the word are you talking
about warrant articles you know the
ballot in March are you talking about
the warrant for taxes it's sent to dra
like in October this may be something
that's unique to education funding so
what happens is it's it's it's actually
a piece of the calculation of aid for
education
and so it's based on one year of
property values
that says how much
has to come how much is going to be
credited from
the Statewide property tax
but when it actually gets assessed is
like I may be missing a part of the
process you're trying to describe but
um it's my understanding that
say a school district's budget is
determined in the deliberative and in
the ballot in March
mm-hmm the rate
for the taxes
necessary to raise the necessary amount
of money that doesn't occur until
October that's absolutely correct that's
what I'm saying
so there's plenty of time to react to
this information so what I'm asking
um him is is is there some way to write
that sentence differently so we can do
it at the time that they're actually
getting ready to send out the tax bills
so um just to clarify that the intent is
not to include that amount from the
Cannabis funds
to reduce to be included or to be
calculated within during the
calculations of the warrant that's
issued by the commissioner
it's such a new proposal I think
probably should think about it some for
some more time but the point would be
that they might use one set of figures
I don't know if they use a
almost go like on a
um
it'll be it would be kind of like an
estimate that they would use
okay I don't know to refocus do you know
the spot in here that you were initially
the point you brought up yes it is on
page 22
um line eight 22 line eight okay
oh so you're saying so the rate should
be effective for the following fiscal
year
um and you are saying what what was the
conflict there again so um the we need
clarification that this rate is
applicable to which fiscal year
um because let's say using the current
situation uh for
23 the commission has already issued the
warrant back in um September 22.
or tax year 23 yeah and then so that
amount has already been informed to the
municipalities what they need to be
collecting in this fiscal year ends June
30th right so you're saying so the
problem with that wording is that it
would apply that it's effective in 24
but it's too late yes the the amount
okay has Mr chairman yes I think this is
a moot point
this only is triggered when there is net
revenue after expenses realized under
the Cannabis tax
and that hasn't happened yet can't
happen till it's enacted can't happen
until it gets up and running in any
given annual cycle the school district's
going to be setting its uh budget in
March the fiscal year for the state will
end June 30th between June 30th and
October November when the tax rate is
set all the information is in and it
takes effect for the following year so
okay I don't think that there is a
problem I don't think it requires any
change in language yeah I agree you're
right by the time Revenue comes in we're
way past this
yeah representative and I think we're
all in agreement we're not going to
realize Revenue whatever that Revenue
may be for at least 15 months if not
pushing two years good point
representative lupley and I apologize
for not getting to you sooner
uh thank you
um
so I think that the proposal is fine
um I agree that the biggest problem many
of our constituents face is their
property taxes and one of their biggest
values is education for their kids and
for future workers in the state so I
think it's it totally makes sense the
breakdown that was laid out I agree
um I just want to come back to revenue
because it doesn't matter if we say
we'll give 50 education if we don't make
any money
so I'm looking and it does look like
Revenue in States who Legalize It looks
like it slowly increases year over year
and that Revenue grows but I noticed
that
um Maine
which is maybe one of the states that's
most like us their revenue
last year
was four million dollars
and that's
based on attacks that's maybe six times
higher than the one that we're
discussing right now so I think it just
comes back to
it doesn't matter where we're going to
put the earned Revenue if there isn't
any so I I want to come back to my
question of can we base
um
the tax rate on
something and what might we look at to
to base it on if not our neighbors so I
agree
with the values that are
that undergird the the distribution
that's been proposed I just want to make
sure there's money to fund those things
thanks okay thank you
um is everyone pretty much in agreement
with representative
um
plan let's hear from representative Ames
yeah I'm not going to challenge that but
I will say
that I think the allocation of money for
Education a is
definitely needed but
um the swap of
one source of State funds for another
doesn't really help education it may
help local property tax rates
but the use of
of a swept reduction
I think
and you can all do your own calculations
plays out in a regressive way so that
the
property the towns that have less
property value produce less swept
and the deduction
and the the it all works out that the
less lower value terms get
um
less help than the higher value Toms I
can stand corrected on that and as I sit
here now I can't do the calculations but
uh that's my understanding and as I say
I don't want to step into the middle of
this right now it's something that's
years away I can live with that
um but uh don't think that we're doing
something for Education when we're just
doing a swap and then also
take a look at what I'm trying to say
about the regressivity of this approach
representative Ami and then
representative Platt
I'm off trying to look at how much
revenue we might get if we were adopting
abrami's
numbers and putting in the increased
amounts that uh
that the Liquor Commission says it needs
and what happens in these next two years
during the budget that they're trying to
do across the hall now
right now on
you you need seven million the first
year eight million the second year when
do you when would you start getting a
license fees
by the way the fiscal note says that
you're getting that that you're supposed
to get 4.6 the first year and two the
second year
which is why I'm asking this
well we did you know
uh representative we did you know some
some checking on the pricing before we
we handed that out we obviously had uh
we checked into the different
programs that are available for it
there's a few companies out there that
are doing the seed to sale transactions
uh
but as far as licensing fees I wouldn't
I wouldn't expect there to be any
licensing fees for at least 18 months to
24 months
because I think that you're going to
have those
manufacturers and Growers get the
license and then invest in the
facilities that they have
and if I could that would be uh
after
the roles are written or that that's
part of the time frame that would be
after the rules are written after and
that takes about a year and a half
wow so that's three years out
and DHHS has got an amendment which I
don't know if anybody else has got they
couldn't stay after this morning uh
there is someone here on which is asking
as I understand it in part for
a piece of the money that is going out
right away so that they can do
education about the effects of cannabis
before the Cannabis is actually there or
not right away I guess it would be
at about the time when you're starting
to license
on and but they also think that the
alternative on
uh cannabis
on centers that we already have the
medical ones on would be they seem to
think they would be immediately
licensing
but that couldn't be done because we
don't have the rules yet
right that would be correct we don't
have the rules is that stream 700
million obviously the the rules only 700
000. sorry everybody
we're trying to you know be conservative
in our estimates and and make sure that
uh we give you timelines that we're
comfortable with I mean 24 months to 36
months is about the timeline that we
feel it would take to get the rules get
the license get the licenses start to
begin to deal with uh the manufacturing
and again it's not to to but I've been
cautioned to make sure that there's
plenty of manufacturing before there's
retail
right
so we're really looking at
on
Appropriations against the budget
on four
the total amount that on
we think should be in the bill
to pay for
what the Liquor Commission has to do on
which the revenues are dependent
and for the DHHS request which is much
smaller but
they were hoping for at least 250
000 to do this campaign before things
get going
representative Platt and then
representative thank you Mr Vice chair
if I I'm hearing correctly I think we've
got General consensus on the wording of
the bill so it comes down to what rate
and I wonder if it's time to caucus
representative alberger
I'm I'm just trying to make sure that
I understand that we're likely not to
get any revenue for about four years
no I I would say 36 months
thank you
representative
thank you Mr chair what somebody's it's
there is somebody here that I'd like to
hear from uh if if you would entertain
him a former representative Egan from
Sugar Hill
who has spent a lot of time on this and
was very involved in the last session
with the bill
um and with uh with with marijuana
legalization particularly the revenue
side of it
could he say a few words
on what to expect maybe from revenues
okay
not I'm not against that I'm I'm
struggling I'm struggling with timing
all right we'll we'll give uh we'll give
two minutes how's that all right thank
you
thank you for coming down I I know that
you've been we've talked a lot about
this and stuff that we can predict and
what we can't predict
um
I was wondering if we've got two minutes
and we'll start when I stop uh just to
say what what kind of predictions or
estimates or or assumptions can we make
about revenues
with following legalization right maybe
in two minutes I can give you some
clarity thank you Mr chair Timothy Egan
Sugar Hill from representative uh
Grafton II I'm the chair of New
Hampshire can the business trade
industry I'm actually also a professor
at Castleton University in the Cannabis
studies program teaching Canada business
and the Cannabis certificate program let
me just give you some information
Vermont's first year projected their
cost per pound is 340 per pound means is
917 per pound Massachusetts which is
correctly everybody addressed has
cratered a bit is 800 to 1500 per pound
Colorado is 650 dollars per pound and
New Jersey is about 560 dollars per
pound
so when you start thinking about if
you're going to tax it at a wholesale
rate or at the the process rate that's
the pound per poundage current going
rate uh the states that are looking at
those same States looking at their
taxation
Vermont has 14 on retail Maine has 10 on
retail
Massachusetts has a 10.75 excise tax on
all transfers
it has a 6.5 6.25 sales tax on top of
that and a three percent locality tax
they actually have a instead of an
opt-in or an opt-out Vermont as you may
know has an opt in towns have to vote to
be able to allow it
I think this bill has a you have to opt
out so Massachusetts adds a three
percent tax on there so you're roughly
looking at about 19.25 sales tax
Colorado has a 15 sales tax as uh excuse
me a marijuana sales tax on top of a 2.9
percent personal sales tax and they also
have a 15 transfer tax
New Jersey has a 6.25
6.625 sales tax and a two percent
transfer tax so as you think about your
tax rates
um
um hearing representative Doucette I
think I remember meeting you a few times
his ideas of ringing in the ear about
making New Hampshire as we are one of
the most competitive States in New
England and this is going to be our our
competition the last thing I'll share
with you then you're talking about
Revenue so Vermont very fresh their
first year projection is 16 million
they're estimated by 2025 is 225 million
where they'd see 46 million dollars of
state revenue
they're the most recent that's why I'm
mentioning them right off the top
because they're the most recent to study
this and October 2022 is when
legalization active doors opened in the
state of Vermont uh Maine as you see as
you heard they made 158 million dollars
in in 2022 with a state revenue net of
16 million their growth was from 82
million in 2021
Massachusetts
tough to put them in this category of
where we're studying our state because
they've been at it so long but their
revenue was 1.4 billion dollars last
year in the Cannabis industry
Colorado same thing they've been at it a
little longer they're 1.8 billion
dollars in gross revenue
and New Jersey is estimating somewhere
around 116 million dollars for their
first year which would be 2022 to 2023
because they're that new
so maybe I took my two minutes well to
give you some numbers and I'm glad to
share this with you more this is what
New Hampshire can does I work actually
closely with new New England cannabis
they're the trade Association around the
six New England states now including New
York New Jersey
so we try to look at what is the
economic impact and I'll leave you with
three thoughts one right now we're
seeing revenu leave the state people are
going to mass Vermont and
Maine so I'm hoping that we can try and
recoup Revenue to
by allowing legalization testing and
regulation we could potentially spawn
new industries that come from the
research of cannabis and the testing of
it not just adult Recreation or
medicinal but other uses and three
the economic development as you begin to
look at all the business services that
could be utilized to build a grow
facility a
processing facility a dispensary the
business profit tax and business
Enterprise taxes of those businesses not
just the ones in the Cannabis industry
but the ones that feed the Cannabis
industry there's an economic
um
multiplier there that has yet to be
determined we're trying to assess that
by looking at Vermont Maine Mass New
Jersey states that are most recent it's
tough to compare our numbers to Oregon
and California and Colorado because
they've had such a long head start even
Massachusetts had a Long Head Start
so glad to answer any more questions I
hope that was helpful thank you
question for him
well that was helpful but on I can't
write that fast and I'm glad to share
this with the entire Community I think
you did
I thought I turned it on you you gave
some context to numbers that ncsl had
had had sent out but that that don't
give on a way of figuring out what
exactly they're taxing how
so I'd I'd love to see anything you've
got written down yeah there's actually a
um two existing pieces of information
out there that exist as there's the
Cannabis Benchmark report which is like
a stock report or a bond report that
analyzes the price per pound of you know
like orange futures or wheat they're now
studying cannabis and looking at the
what is the average price per pound in
America of cannabis it's that much of a
of a focused Revenue generating industry
that they're beginning to track it like
anything else as well MJ bizcom does a
you know annual report on States and
evaluating the state's Revenue
generation their excise tax their sales
tax their costs as well as what impacts
things in what other rules and Rule
making within their agencies impact the
industry like advertising or no use of
billboards or things like that
the cost per pound at what level of
Taxation is right and that's and that
applies to each different state the
current
like if you're looking at the price of
gold today the current cost per pound
um
is
as of uh
it's 971 dollars per pound for the
nation as of March 17th
is is plain gold it's the same right how
each state applies their taxation
process their legalization process
licensing process too it does affect
that I'm just trying to give you the
Benchmark that the nation uses when the
when when you're taxing the gold as it
comes out of the mud pit
in Brazil on do you pay pay what we
would call Pennies on the dollar
versus if you're taxing it at the
Jewelers
right henceforth the conversation I've
been listening to all day which is your
it is a challenge to build this and
what I'm saying by coming forward and
asking
um thank you representative for
recognizing me
um I'm here and the industry is here to
help you with information to help you
build a bill that is the best interest
of everyone in New Hampshire so
um we're glad to do that as well support
our agencies um you know I did have four
years in the house and I understand sort
of the the process here and so I know
there's a lot of data collection it has
to go on and you have to hear from a
variety of sources so we're glad to
support that in any way shape or form
and I want to be respectful let them
weigh over my two minutes
and if I could follow up oh I'm here for
you yeah you're
you're one thing that uh struck me was
that when you gave the net revenue to
the state it was a lot less than the
gross revenue to the state
uh in the states that you did that for
which was only some of them
right every business has startup costs
and we will as you heard we will assume
those
well we are in a very difficult
right now and um
we have to look very carefully I think
it how much it's going to cost to start
up
as part of this
okay I think that the if we don't give
that money to The Liquor Commission it
won't get started up
but if we do we're talking about 15
million in the next by this biennium
coming up
at a minimum
okay um I wouldn't agree with that but I
well that's what they just said
thank you thank you for your testimony
we appreciate it
um did anyone else have any questions
for him you have one I just wanted
clarification because I heard some
pretty big Revenue numbers from you and
um I think that all the states you were
talking about have a retail
cannabis tax in were you also adding in
things like sale taxes and how that
translates to what we have how does that
you know transfer to what we're looking
at which is attacks only on wholesale
right so I mentioned the states that
have that I have sales tax and transfer
or wholesale taxes and then states that
just have retail I think that your fact
that you're choosing one or the other
not both is smart
unsolicited I'm more in the preference
of a lower cultivation tax or a vape or
rooms and meals tax but that's I'm not
on the committee making those decisions
but that's my where I'd lean but it's
also whatever is prudent for looking at
generating the most Revenue
to representative leapley did you have a
question
and then representative spilsberg
yeah I think that the numbers
um that our guests provided
Jive totally with the numbers we've been
looking at all day and the main numbers
the Vermont numbers this is revenue this
is total tax revenue so Maine as we've
been discussing has an excise tax and a
sales tax
um so if you're just looking at the
excise tax it's ten percent but if you
add in the sales tax it's 5.5 percent
you put them both together you get
apparently in 2022 60 million last last
year it was like
12.9 I think in Maine so I I just want
to come back to the point that I think
we have to to me
I'm looking at all of the facts in front
of us and
it just looks like 15 retail
is the starting point
where other taxes other states are
taxing this at the retail level with the
exception of New Jersey and in Maine
they also have
and 335 dollars per pound excise tax on
flour 94 dollars per pound on trim 150
or one dollar fifty cents per seedling
30 cents per seed that's before you get
to the retail excise tax of 10 and then
add on that the state sales tax of 5.5
percent
so I just it seems really clear from all
of the information we've been given
what is kind of out there for taxation
so I think that we can be New Hampshire
and have low taxes without
missing out on millions of dollars of
Revenue and if this committee is
interested in some of the tax cuts that
have come before us or that have been
cut in the last few years like we're
losing IND income
people are proposing to tax the
communications tax or cut the
communications tax
I I mean it's Ways and Means so our job
is to find Revenue so if we're going to
legalize this I think our constituents
would expect us to tax it in a in
alignment with the way we tax tobacco
the way we tax um other things that
impose that will impose a cost on people
who live in New Hampshire so we need to
cover those costs and then it would be
nice if we could generate Revenue
um so I'm hoping that we can come back
with a number that is
on the planet Earth
and comparable to other states in the
union that's my hope for Monday
okay let's let's um in an attempt to try
to get the tax part wrapped up let's I
want to hear from
people as to what what is your proposed
tax we've kind of understood where
people are coming from now let's
we know representative Doucette is
proposing eight percent that's why I
asked for caucus
well let's
um we don't have enough did I come back
to you representative spilsbury you had
something you were going to say
I waved off oh you did okay
um
does anyone have
a thought on the actual tax so
um I I agree that if if we were doing a
a retail tax that 15 would be like the
starting point and and I'd like to see
it more but you know I wouldn't get
upset over 15. but if we're going to do
it at the wholesale level we have to
have something that's comparable to that
and what we heard is that when you move
the tax to the wholesale level the you
know what you're taxing is a lot less
expensive than the retail you're only
going to get about 25 percent
so the what's comparable to a 15 percent
retail tax would be a 60 wholesale tax
so I'm not really suggesting 60 but 15
is just ludicrous I mean we won't we
won't even take us like five or six
years just to pay off the startup costs
and then we're looking at revenues like
maybe a a maybe 10 million a year so
it if we're going to do wholesale it has
to be comparable to what would be raised
at a retail rate of 15 or more
representative Doucet
circling back here we've heard a lot of
input a lot of testimony I stand on my
ground I don't necessarily care how
anybody else does it I don't care that
they have a sales tax I don't care what
the rate of their sales tax is people in
my town of Salem New Hampshire voted for
me and those people want me to control
taxes most specifically they don't want
a sales and or an income tax and I've
made them that promise also they're
talking to me about this very issue
legalization that we all know is coming
I want to do it right I want to do it
the New Hampshire way I want to make it
affordable we can make comparisons to
other states well here's a great
comparison our border with the border of
Massachusetts that does 1.2 or 1.4
billion dollars in cannabis sales it's a
big border I happen to live on that
border we're going to get some of that
Revenue into this state I think we
undercut the competition whether it be
Black Market or whether it be Maine
Massachusetts Vermont or anybody else I
I again retort that the 15 was a
hypothetical nobody testified as to why
there was a 15 tax I my belief is this
puts us like I said earlier tip of the
spear cheapest in the country done the
New Hampshire way done right regulated
correctly
you know we're making comparisons I'd
like to compare compare our liquor
Revenue to any other state in in the
country
okay we can do cannabis right we do a
lot of things right in New Hampshire and
this is the right thing to do start in
undercut the competition set the mark
set the bar as the 603 and go for it
representative spilsbury and then
elberger
so this is a brand new adventure there's
no empirical data
it's making the debate itself difficult
because numbers are being thrown around
that
are being rounded or used Loosely and
you come to a certain point where you
just need to get started
so we've already had a vote on the house
floor and the house has decided it wants
to proceed with this legislation
where we set the rate today at the
outset
really doesn't govern where that rate is
going to end up once we start to see the
program unfold let's let's let's go with
the 15 given that exit the wholesale
level
I would be for eight percent or less if
it was the retail level
I don't buy the idea that the difference
between wholesale and reset re and
Retail would require the rate to be four
times
I don't buy the idea of 45 or 60 percent
I think it's fantasy
I think we need to kick off a program
and give the Liquor Commission the
advantage of getting it started
recognizing that it's going to take
12 to 15 months to even initiate
rulemaking under the terms of the bill
and it's going to take 24 to 36 months
to get it rolling to get licenses out
and another legislature will come back
with more information
and the benefit of being able to reset
the rate if and when the data indicates
it should be
so I I'm I'm all for sticking with the
rate that we've received from the
Commerce Committee
representative lburger and then play
thank you
um
I may have different constituents from
those of Representative Doucet but I
will tell you that when I was
campaigning last year the biggest issue
that they presented to me was high
property taxes and whatever we can do to
help lower property taxes will be will
make more of them happier than any other
financial decision that I think we can
make
um
I happen to believe that
if we were to go in with a lower tax
rate at this point and say well you know
if we need to we can make it higher in a
couple of years that that will fall flat
on its face because
New Hampshire as we know doesn't like
taxes and doesn't like tax increases so
if we start low getting it higher even
if we determine that it's necessary will
be a very very difficult thing to
accomplish
I'm comfortable with 15 at retail
and particularly if it means that at
some point we can help lower property
taxes
I agreed with everything that represents
Pillsbury said except the rate and I buy
a lot of what a representative Doucet
says we want a really undercut illegal
trade none of the other states have done
it
and so to get it low enough to undercut
the retail rate and then attract
business across the border our way that
doesn't mean I'm died in the wool over
eight percent I want to have a caucus
yes
um we have a 68 percent tax on Tobacco
but it's much lower than our neighbors
and we undercut them on cigarette sales
we look like we smoke more two times
more than anybody else in the country uh
on the statistics uh
if we are trying to lower this to the
point where we are not going to be able
to pay enough for the Liquor Commission
work
and keep the product safe and keep the
product tasting okay we are not going to
undercut anybody
and I think that you are getting down to
a level where it is really hard to tell
with all of of the complications of the
way each state defines where and what
they're taxing but
it looks to me like
15 is the lowest that's going to help us
with this and it looks to me like we're
going to have some trouble with the
budgeters about the three year Hiatus
that we've we have to have
um this bill has got the Appropriations
in it at uh half and a quarter of the
amount that they're going to need and
they're going to have other revenue for
it
representative lippley thank you
um
so just some reflection
if
when we run we're running against
raising income taxes and against sales
taxes which
most people in New Hampshire are running
on
we're not running on well I guess some
people are running on not having a state
that is definitely a group of people who
are running in New Hampshire but if this
isn't a sales tax right we just
negotiated so it's not a sales tax it's
on the manufacturing
that was very important to members of
this committee and we came to an
agreement that it's a wholesale
manufacturing tax not a sales tax right
so I think that was essential to many
people here
it's not a sales tax it's not an income
tax
we have to raise revenue somehow in the
state if we are opposed to raising
revenue on income taxes and on sales
taxes then we should have taxes that are
not income taxes or sales taxes so that
we can take in revenue and run our state
because at this point we keep cutting
taxes
um and we're running out of places to
cut and we're running out of money so
because it's not an income tax and
because it's a sale not a sales tax I
think that we should vote for it thank
you
thank you representative Doucet just
just a final comment here no nobody
we've heard numbers thrown around we've
heard figures thrown around we've heard
assumptions thrown around as to how
things are going to be paid for nobody
nobody knows what the revenue is going
to be generated nobody okay and to to uh
couple off of my my colleague from
Lebanon that's right we do tobacco right
we do liquor right let's do cannabis
right let's beat our neighbors
let's do it with this component
let's um
let's take a let's take a
I was going to say five minute let's
take a 10 minute break
um I want to be back here at 10 of
so 10 minutes maximum break Republicans
are going to caucus in this room
um and we'll be back at 10 of
we need everybody to leave the room I'm
sorry at 10 of
10 of you can come back
um I think we have everybody back that's
still left
all right let's um let's try to finish
up what we're doing
so a couple things one is um
we are not going to be discussing the
the actual the rate anymore will will
finalize what the rate should be on
Monday we're missing several members
and um
what we're gonna what we're gonna try to
finish up on is representative Doucet
has an amendment that's been passed out
you all have it
um he's just going to hit a couple
points in there that we haven't gone
over yet
and then um
some of the other changes that we've
discussed uh today will be put into a
new Amendment for Monday
and um so we'll have uh representative
doucet's updated Amendment on Monday and
then we also have an amendment from DHHS
which we will not discuss today they've
got some technical change I guess are
they technical changes or what are they
represented all me just
your speaker
oh
this is like no put your speaker on
my speaker on sorry
on
they want
they a lot of it is just name changes
they don't want Substance Abuse
Prevention and Recovery they want
substance use but and creation and
promotion of scientifically and
medically accurate public education
committees instead of just
scientifically and they want to create
these okay and
but they do and
and explaining better what the the costs
are for the Dual use the alternative
treatment centers
when they do both sides of it
um okay
but there is something else in here that
it's been a while since I even decided
to look at it
they did want as part of this at least I
think 250
000 up before
the Cannabis sales started
before that so that they could
um
could um education and do an education
campaign to Youth and vulnerable adults
okay all right so we will discuss that
Amendment on Monday
and um at this point Let's uh
representative Doucet go through the
amendment
okay yeah the only component Amy
there's there's three uh former
representative of Rami brought a uh a
sheet with issues that he he saw and in
reading that myself and a couple others
um a lot of what he gave to us
was policy stuff we we picked out at
least I picked out three very specific
technical changes that had to be
addressed and we did that in this
amendment and I can point you to on page
13 of the bill line 26
um simply
in the colon where it says D it should
be a c
pretty simple
on page 21 lines 16 and 17.
we struck the following language
where it reads
and deposits into the fund by the
commissioner of the Department of
Revenue Administration pursuant to RSA
77h
that's uh page 21
line The End of Line 16 into 17.
it's uh and deposits into the fund the
commissioner of Department of Revenue
Administration pursuant to RSA 77h
well we struck that all out
stuck it all out okay
also on page 21
on line 22 an unneeded word uh simply
line 22 the second word in cannabis just
uh the commission should read
on page 22
lines 13 through 14.
I'm going to change the following words
see it's
13 14 at the end okay based on the
percent of
striking out tax revenue collected
instead reading based on the percentage
percent of Statewide sales at retail
stores located in the municipality
this is going to become rope could you
repeat exactly it'll become moot by the
other Amendment so I'm just going
through what I have in front of you
so we should probably skip over that and
and the remainder of that amendment is
just the uh change from 15 to 8 percent
of cultivation
questions representative plett not with
anything that representative set covered
so far but on his Amendment the last two
lines
the tax on the monthly total gross
revenue of licensed cannabis cultivation
facilities imposed at the rate of eight
percent setting aside the eight percent
for the moment that's a discussion for
Monday
it should the wording be broadened
licensed cannabis cultivation facilities
or
yeah we're going to integrate uh what
representative spilsberry will speak to
in the language that we all spoke about
earlier great and
integrated
this is just a draft
anything else
yes representative
put your microphone on
on page 32 of the bill amended bill
um we have
section 33 Appropriations and section 33
Appropriations uh aside from the hundred
thousand on
for one year given to the Department of
Safety drug monitoring initiative we
have
on four thousand four million six
hundred dollars given to the Liquor
Commission strike cannabis uh for
or
whatever they decide to call us now
on for the cost of administration on and
on a warrant on for the fiscal year
ending June 30th 2024
um so that's the first year of the next
budget
on
to draw a warrant for said some from any
money in the treasury not otherwise
appropriated that money is going to be
going on
not from the governor's warrants but in
the budget as a
on
end of the book
deduction from the amount available for
the budget
and it's been going to The Liquor
Commission which says it needs 7 million
that first year
on then it says 2 million for the fiscal
year ended June 30th 2025 appropriated
to the commission is established for
deposit into the Cannabis fund
for the administration of RSA 318f
that money is the same thing it comes
out of the budget in the back of the
budget and reduces what they can use in
the front of the budget on and on it is
five million six million below what they
said they needed that year
and so
do we just leave it like this and in the
Assumption the whole thing is going to
fail anyway or
or do we change the Appropriations or do
we decide that they they don't know how
much it costs them to do the business
and it could be less and let's just say
it's less
but going down from 8 million to 2
million seems to me uh pretty hard for
them to do and function
thoughts
which is one more thing to discuss on
Monday
well I want people to think about it and
that's right that's exactly right that
is a good point good
all right
representative spilsbury
yeah while while we're contemplating the
timing there and the amount
I just want to draw attention to an
inconsistency
on page 32
particularly focusing on line nine
subparagraph two
the sum of two million for the fiscal
year ending June 30th 2025 which implies
for the second year of the biennium but
the language that's used back
on page
online 21 talks about an appropriation
for the biennium
and so we're using the terminology
appropriation for the biennium in one
place and for the fiscal year and the
other
so they should be reconciled and that's
also true with the
paragraph two for the biennium
and
paragraph 5A uh 100 000 for the
Department of Safety I need to examine
this a little bit more myself to make
sure I've sorted it out and what's right
but we've got two different areas of the
law talking about the same thing in
different terms
what's interesting
that's the one that doesn't existing
right okay
thank you
okay
I think there was just a typo in lines
18 to 22. it was
the biennium and the
Roman 2 says the biennium ending in June
30. uh and every biennium thereafter
they will shall include the cost of
administration into the commission's
efficiency expenditure request it's too
late for that
by about 10 12 months 10 months at this
point
on
and then they say that 2002 million is
it in Romans 3 they say for the biennium
ending
on
June 30th
2025 the sum of 2 million is here I
appropriated commission for the cost of
administration of this chapter
and then the Appropriations at the end
are look different from that maybe
they're additive I have no idea
I guess the question is do we want to
authorize or appropriate so that they
can spend 2 million at any time over the
two-year cycle
or are we trying to pin them down to
spending it only in the second year of
the biennium
so
if they spend 15 million
in the two startup years they said they
need they're buying all of those data
management programs and learning how to
use them they want seven million in the
first year including some personnel and
eight million in the second year
including a lot more all of the
personnel
and then in the third year they need
what they think they'll need going
forward which is 4.2 million but all of
that is more than what
went into this
and all of that would be additive until
they start getting some money back
which is at the end of the third year
as I recall into the fourth year they're
going to be getting money back and
that's when they'll start paying that
back because it says that some shall be
a charge against the fund
so um
the finances of this are rather messy
any other thoughts
I mean the
it'd be nice to get this
straightened out and added to the
amendment for Monday
um
is that something that
yeah let's when we can sit down and
convince ourselves we're thinking
straight
we will try to add that and of course we
will we will cue OLS into the likelihood
that some tweaks will be required while
we're assembled on Monday I would I
would think that would be a good good
bet
okay
all right
um
I guess Monday we'll have
separate amendments about some parts of
this
but I hate to have to
think separately about whether we're
accepting their numbers for what it
takes them to do
I'd hate to think that Monday we're
going to have to be arguing about
whether we're accepting their numbers
for what they say they have to do
um or we're going to try and cut them
back some
and whether we just put the
Appropriations at the end or and dropped
what was in 21 sorry drop what was in
21.
which
on
but which does say where the funding is
coming from for the Cannabis fund
and by the way that cannabis fund would
according to the amendment we've got now
should have been
been liquor and cannabis fund I think
maybe not no he said he's not just
cannabis yeah it's One Fund they're not
going to come in they don't they aren't
they don't they don't come mango
mingle so the question is what this
thing gets called
yeah consistent probably the Cannabis
fund yes thank you Mr chairman
um
representative Doucette and I will
prepare an amendment that incorporates
the things we've discussed today
including the two proposals that I had
made earlier
um we our Amendment will not address the
question of the amount of the
appropriation
okay so if somebody thinks that's
something they want to do it would be
separate I'll I'll work on that okay
representative Almy will work on that
all right uh representative Platt Mr
chair this discussion has given me a
real high yeah but uh I think I'm in a
haze right now are we done for the day
pretty much
I think we are done for today I thank
everyone for their patience I think we
made good progress on a difficult uh
um Bill and a lot of a lot of detail and
you know I'm sure there's there's still
more to come but Monday we'll reconvene
it in the meantime
um representative spillsberry
representative Doucette will work on
many of the issues uh we talked about
and representative almi will
work on the um
the the funding
okay anything else
we will meet uh what time are we meeting
I think we're meeting at 11 o'clock
we are meeting at 11 o'clock on Monday
for an executive session on HB
uh 639 yes
given that it may be another long day is
there any way to start it maybe an hour
earlier I don't know why it's that's
representative Sanborn has already put
that actually is that already in like
it's surely put in the calendar at 11.
it can't be changed
it probably still could
she could change it in this coming
calendar
it still can be changed but I'll I'll
talk to her about starting it
I have an oil fund disbursement board
meeting from eight to nine okay yeah so
I'd have trouble getting here ten no 10
would be fine but I'll talk to her about
seeing if we can push it back to 10.
they can't do that just call a work
session at 10.
we're going to be in a work session when
we start executing anyway
all right well I'll talk to her and see
what she wants to do did you have
right yeah yeah well representative
alberga was asking if we could start at
10.
well I don't think we can start earlier
I think we were but I don't know whether
uh
the other side was talking about having
a caucus prior too but I think that was
part of the Chairman's uh oh was it
logic
well assume it's at 11 if it changes
you'll be noticed
all right thank you everyone